[Music]
scared to push it
push it seems to be going that's what
she said
[Laughter]
and you shut up and said and said get
off of her
just kidding the um
yeah it's good now well like i said
don't jinx it we had to re-verify [ __ ]
evidently through jenny's phone well
because i had to get a new phone and now
every time like i appreciate you know
that they're trying to
make sure that nobody's stealing my
information as lame as my information is
um you know what i mean but it's getting
to a point now where's just like is this
you oh my god verify this verify that
we're sending this to your phone we're
sending that channel i'm like [ __ ] it's
me
all right yeah [ __ ] yeah i have three
computers and a phone so it's like every
time i
log into a site on one of the different
computers they're like it's a
it's a strange person yep everybody's
showing up it's me
everybody's here maniacs here david june
uh
david we set your uh shirts out was it
yesterday yesterday
yeah we went we went out in the rain to
the yeah to the post office yeah you got
an extra shirt coming too
because uh i [ __ ] the first one
[ __ ]
the logos on the front is [ __ ]
crooked and that's what it wasn't
crooked like that it was crooked like
too far over
over a little bit and uh because it was
the first time i was working with a
[ __ ]
was it 4xl yeah x4 xl3x i think it's 4xl
dude david i know you said you liked
them a little bit bigger
you said i i like it a little bit bigger
get some extra room at 4x
dude it's like dealing with the [ __ ]
tent it's like dealing with a tent david
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then and then the little label looks
tiny on it so i talked to jenny today i
was like
i want a bigger one i want to sell the
whole size of a whole plate
yeah because what the screens we have
are what eight by ten yeah eight half by
eleven something like that but
foot it's like a foot by eight inch ten
inches by twelve in it
so yeah oh maybe it is pretty big yeah
but i think the ends i don't know i have
to remember
yeah the inner diameter might look but
the thing about it is that the plisken
when i made that you told me to make the
design smaller
yeah like on this this size shirt
on a bigger shirt it needs to be a
bigger
yeah we could do any i still have the
design yeah and it's it's vector so i
can make it as big
for larger sizes i want a bigger image
so we're going to make a bigger image
and a bigger image would look good on a
shirt this size too it would just be a
different application of it
yeah yeah i mean i mean we've got [ __ ]
tons of uh i got
yeah i got screens i still haven't
showed you that the new shirt design i
did
no i don't know like the ouija board one
okay yeah i want to see him see
i thought it came out we got gotta get
that [ __ ] done but uh you'll get it in a
couple days so you got two coming and
one of them is a reject
what am i gonna do sell it well yeah we
had already we had already cooked it
the ink on there and then when we put it
up like to take a picture of it look at
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh it's like it's how did that get
wherever it is because we thought it was
like right in the middle where the tag
and the [ __ ] was
that's not how it worked out once we
killed it because and we weren't drunk
when we were doing it we had to put a
plate
in there underneath the shirt so it
doesn't bleed through when you when you
when you when you shoot it
and i guess we just kind of had it in
there crooked and it got it
it was hard to find out where the
sleeves you know where the shoulders
ended
we hadn't worked with one with a shirt
that size we had a special order that
shirt now from here on out
uh just just heads up to people i think
what is it
2xl 3xl and 4xl they're they're more
expensive so we're going to have to
charge more
i have to yeah i have to check you we
get all our shirts from jiffy shirts
yeah and i can't remember what the
cutoff is for them getting
more it's a significant it's
significantly more
because i think small medium large
perhaps extra-large
are like between three and four dollars
a piece
like for the blank ones right but after
shipping and everything but then i think
that at that 2xl
goes up a dollar and then 3xl goes up a
dollar of course or something like that
i can't
i thought it was more than that well it
depends on what kind of shirt you get
too because they have a [ __ ] ton of
different they have right
you know regular cotton they have mixed
cotton they have soft feel
they have you know boat neck crew neck
v-neck
of all different kinds i remember just
doing the math in my head
and three and four xl if you sell them
for twenty dollars
after [ __ ] youtube if you sell for
twenty dollars out of chat room
after [ __ ] youtube takes its cut
which it takes thirty percent of that
and then
after the expenses we really don't make
anything
off of a 3xl yeah 20. it's gonna have to
be more like 30
and we end up making about six bucks on
it that's
that's that's that's more they cost
about i mean for
you know like i said small medium large
i think extra large if i'm just sending
one shirt like in an envelope
i can usually send those oh thanks david
jing yeah he sent us a spider oh that's
great
that's cool they yeah they usually cost
about five bucks to ship
if there's just one shirt in there
obviously you know more shirts are gonna
cost more but you know
depends on shipping but now you're gonna
you're gonna enjoy it i said i sent you
a picture
you liked it i sent you a picture of it
yeah yeah but i'm gonna get some we're
going to get some new shirt offerings
out we we have a lot of blank shirts and
stuff yeah i
bought like a hundred blank shirts of
various several hundred dollars worth of
[ __ ] blank shirts yeah it was like
250 bucks worth
yeah so we got to get some some good
images that will sell
briskly and
yeah i'm getting sick of wearing these
because these are like my uniform shirts
i got like four of these
yeah and like three of the 13 o'clock
ones every time we do
a pliskin shirt for somebody he just
makes another one for him
what every time we do a pliskin shirt
you usually make another one for you or
you make an extra one
no the first few times the first few
times i did yeah i don't have it anymore
i don't
i got enough of them yeah because you
got like three or four of them yeah i
got like three for them
but yeah we'll have we'll do some more i
know we keep saying that but we just
haven't gotten around to
it like i said i got to show you that
design i did i want them at least to be
like club worthy too
like something i'd wear to a club yeah
yeah that ouija one looks like
that yeah so i think okay i mean i have
to
i i designed it a while back and i think
now i can't remember what it looked like
some you know where to go it looks like
a ouija board is what it looks like
except it's got it's except it says 13
o'clock podcast in
instead of an alphabet one of the
designs is going to be paramilitary
i think i'm going to make a 506 or a 327
shirt
some of the unit that like a like a unit
one of the units i served in and i'm
going to
do a 13 o'clock mashup with that and you
know what i mean
yeah so if you guys want it it'll
probably be something like cross rifles
with the unit name on it and like a 13
o'clock logo in there somehow we're
going to work it out
yeah just give me an idea it's going to
look kind of paramilitary got like a
um you know 13 o'clock army shirt
sure why not yeah that'd be cool it's
like something i would wear
yeah you know yeah the guys will like it
and you know we
like i said we have female cut t-shirts
too and i want
some like female wife beaters and i want
male wife beaters i have a few of those
in black yeah you know like the
kind of white beater ones cause some of
these designs would look good on a
girl's shirt especially if you got
like if you like jenny you got big boobs
yeah big boobs anything looks good
stretched across some big boobs as long
as the shape's right actually
yeah yeah tammy keeps saying we need a
13 o'clock at regular shirt
we probably should like all the people
that come and hang out in the oh like a
regular room yeah
yeah yeah except they're called
irregulars because there were a bunch of
warehouses yeah
that would actually that would actually
match up with the with a paramilitary
theme
we'll see there you go yeah it's all
coming together
i gotta write that down because i'm sure
i've wrote it down before but i probably
would go
on a page that got put somewhere
i'm so organized yeah let's see
everybody's talking about i mean i'm
kind of organized but i could be
i could be organized or yeah tammy
youtube takes 30 percent
does it really i didn't think i said
that yeah it's 30 well we still
get quite we heard it was 30. quite a
bit like just because it's not in super
chats it's also ad revenue yeah but i'm
talking about on super chat the super
chat i think they get 30
oh okay well yeah lots of luck i never i
never looked into it
yeah it also says she has our 13 o'clock
shirt and she was really comfortable
good quality yeah we tried to get the
best quality shirts we could get
and if it if it doesn't come out right
when i'm
shooting it i don't accept it uh you
know see
the the dye that we use as long as it
isn't cooked in
will rinse right out so if it didn't
come out right
i'll just throw it in the sink and rinse
it out and i'll grab another shirt
that's dry
yeah and i'll try it again and if
there's anything i don't really like
about it doesn't really meet up my
standards i don't send it to you
yeah so if i wouldn't wear it i'm not
going to give it to you
yeah and we cook them we have a heat gun
yeah
one of them got by me somebody
complained that it was a little bit off
center
and i offered to [ __ ] replace it but
they said don't worry about it
so it's just whatever if you have a
problem with with anything that we make
just
give me a heads up singing i'm going to
ask for photo
confirmation that it is [ __ ] up and
you know i'll pick it up
got to prove that [ __ ] i prove it's
[ __ ] up if you prove it's [ __ ] up
i'll make another one
because you can't just get be getting
free shirts willy-nilly
yeah does the middle tier patreon
membership come with a shirt i don't
think it does i think it's just the
twenty dollars but like i said
if you just like give twenty dollars
once on the weekend 71 sleeves and
cheese says i was going through customs
with that pliskin shirt and the customer
dude was like yeah
snake pliskin if you ask me that's my
favorite design
i kind of came up with the idea and
jenny did a [ __ ] great job executing
it i wanted to i wanted just the damn
ford cobra logo with pliskin written on
top it looks like something out of like
a 1960s racing [ __ ]
yeah campaign i like it yeah and it does
kind of have a little bit of a military
flair to it
i like it i want a little slightly
bigger one this would look really good
on an od green shirt with print printed
in black
too so that's another thing i was
considered to do oh yeah
cause we bought some other colors of ink
like i bought some red and i bought some
blue
but you always have to like do
especially on a black shirt you always
have to do
like a white layer underneath otherwise
it won't show up
because i did a shirt for me with a red
13 o'clock logo on it and it's like you
can barely see it
grant this wanted to know if a middle if
the middle tier i i just answered that
oh did you always listen yeah yeah yeah
i was probably
reading the comments what was the answer
no i don't think it is no like i said i
think it's just
i think it's just 20 and up but like i
said if you just um
you know if you want a shirt excuse me
if you want a shirt
and you just like throw us 20 bucks in
the chat yeah tell us which one you want
right as long as it isn't like a real
big shirt
yeah as long as it isn't like 2xl or
bigger yeah because then you might be
just like i can give it to you
yeah because those black shirts are like
they cost yeah they're probably closer
to like 30 for 2xl and bigger
yeah i mean like i said it's a sliding
scale up to xl i think they're
you know three four dollars a piece for
a blank one but then
i mean obviously i like the soft feel
cotton ones yes and those are like
slightly more
i think they're 4 21 or something like
that and if it's a bigger order
something bulk you want several shirts
or maybe you want something a little bit
different we could talk about it we'll
talk about it over over
uh messenger i could probably give you a
better bulk price
yes you know some people might want six
shirts like i did
i get it i did a deal with uh sleeves
and cheese and [ __ ] i sent him you
know for some [ __ ] that happened and you
know which does between me and him
and i think i sent him six shirts yeah i
think it was six or seven yeah yeah
which uh was a good deal had he paid 20
bucks a piece for each one of them
yeah so well there you go yeah so i can
do [ __ ] like that
you can do [ __ ] like that so
uh yeah sleazy cheese said might have
turned this customs girl onto your
podcast she asked about the podcast logo
on the back
oh yeah and uh yeah they told told her
what
what it was about all right so that's
cool yeah cool
see that's like the whole reason for
people wearing those
well yeah i wanted my own cool shirts
that i could wear too that were about
the shirt yeah that's really kind of
what started it
yes and i said these would sell yeah you
know
and and the idea was first to just give
them to uh
20 and up patrons just as like extra
merch
but then as people started to [ __ ] oh
people started asking us in the in the
chats
hey man i want one of those shirts how
much yeah so then that just opened up
that
that opened up that that avenue that
avenue so then we just decided we bought
like a shit-ton
of screens we bought a [ __ ] ton of blank
shirts i have like half
my side of the closet as all blank
t-shirts yeah
i got a i got a bunch of sizes i got
freaking weyland yutani
and i got whalen shirts uh from from
alien
i i they came out really good but
they're they're not really good sellers
if somebody asks for them i'll i'll send
you some
you know i can show you guys what it
looks like but um
i want stuff that [ __ ] on that you
know for some reason this shirt
me wearing this shirt on the show and
the other one people have just in the
chat says i want that shirt
yeah so i want designs that have that
much impact
and amanda said i haven't received a
shirt from you guys in forever yeah we
haven't done a
mail out in a long time like we really
need to get behind
on it we're we're way behind on yeah
like i said by a
couple months i apologize for that we
just we just get so behind on
we're we're behind on so much other we
actually it's time to actually do those
we have it in stock
we got to do that we got to finish the
cookbook i want to get the cookbook done
by the end of this weekend there's
literally
all we have to do all i have to do
is take pictures right and
uh write the introduction i think that's
it and we have to read through it again
and make sure it's okay but other than
that
our biggest problem with the point with
the patrons in the shirts
is that we'll send out a notice about
what
size shirt you want and what pattern do
you want on it and and you guys never
respond
well sometimes some people are some
people most people don't
i usually i don't know like because
sometimes i send people emails like with
the email address that they signed up
for patreon for
yeah so i usually get about 75 percent
of the people like return the emails but
then like 25 percent of people don't
okay well on patreon
a patreon send out send out a message
ask them what size they want and what
design yeah
and we'll get that done like i have a
list of all the sizes that people
told me but like i said i always i
always check again every single time
because sometimes people
you know they might have gained weight
or lost weight or they're like i don't
want one for me
somebody else or something like that so
i always like i don't want to just like
send people whatever yeah we don't know
what we sent you last
and some people might want two of one
yeah because i can't remember
we don't keep those kind of records it's
just what you want so we sent out a
notice
this week sent out a notice to all the
patrons okay ask them what size they
want right shirt
i'm gonna write that down gotta get that
done i'll try to get that i'll try to
get on with it
we're gonna try and get all the shirts
down try to get them mailed out next
week and i want to get that [ __ ]
cookbook done too
yeah which means we gotta do a photo
shoot yeah
sometime okay cause i just i want some
pictures
some pictures of you with your chef
jacket wherever where is your chef
jacket i haven't seen it i got it
oh okay i haven't seen it we got 33 on
board right now this is good
i'm even gonna photo i'm gonna photoshop
a chef hat on you
i got one i don't think you have a chef
out i think you should i'll get one i'll
get one
i think you just have well i will that
would be easier
to give you french
[Laughter]
you actually just wear a [ __ ] do-rag
on your head that's the that's the chef
right
that's [ __ ] tired dude well you could
well yeah that's that's what we wear
mostly well yeah well and you can
probably we probably have something like
that around here
or you uh you know um uh we
you had the little [ __ ] you know i
don't want to be rude and call them [ __ ]
caps
that's the flat ones they're white
because it looks like a [ __ ] like a cut
when it's [ __ ] folded up okay
yeah put that kind of cap put your hands
up in the puzzle
[Laughter]
but you're putting your whole head in
the position climbing back into the womb
yeah exactly i like that i think that
that sounds like a 90s riot girl band
yeah
yeah hi we're [ __ ] cap there goes the
monitors
there goes the monetization yeah
oh my god what did somebody say she like
a
wife beater that'd be her pick yeah okay
yeah cause i see what she wear
says you're pregnant you're preggers
right now though you know i mean you
wear white blade when you're pregnant
yeah why not yeah she's gonna have to
get uh pregnant once she heads up
you're gonna have to get on pregnant you
get not pregnant you have to depregate
yourself impregnate yourself
she's getting ready to pop anyway though
getting ready all right question for tom
does russia get invaded ukraine and
sparta
park off world war iii yes russia will
take ukraine and china is going to make
a move on taiwan
and there will not be an american
response the hope
that's why they're going to do it they
know
america's state of readiness right now
is just like abysmal
um if you're going to go toe-to-toe with
first of all they would never go to toe
to toe with china
because china owns our ruling class
they've invested all their money over
there
our ruling class actually wants us to
adopt the chinese model with the social
credit score and all that kind of [ __ ] a
totalitarian control grid
that they would love that because our
ruling class doesn't like american law
because it keeps them under control they
want a law that keeps us under control
and they can do whatever they want
so they can go have these little child
islands and
[ __ ] all these dudes who did not kill
themselves because they did not die
uh their our ruling class is bad and
they don't live here a lot of them
um so they'll we'll never go to war with
china we're china's [ __ ]
now uh russia
you have to understand what russia is
when you think of russia
today most people would think of the
soviet union which is this nuclear-armed
superpower with a huge army and all this
whole armored force
and millions of millions of armed
infantry though that's all
obsolete you can't win wars with that
equipment anymore
uh modern warfare is fifth generational
warfare it's done with armies of lawyers
protesters and agents and
propaganda outlets mind control
that's how you win wars the russian army
doesn't look like the soviet army at all
most of the most of the effective
russian military is
a mercenary force similar to ours you
know like they have their own versions
of black water and they
employ their own
private help uh you know we would call
them terrorists
but we employ those too uh united states
is also a sponsor state sponsor of
terror
uh we were hiring terrorists to uh
attack syria
and they were fighting us we were
fighting the russians in syria
uh over the fact that russia wanted to
put a pipeline through syria that's all
that's about has nothing to do with
their government or this assad
it's about that [ __ ] pipeline if
russia builds that pipeline through
there
it'll hurt our oil income and so that
that's all that is
you have to understand that we are not
the good guys
we're the bad guys but so is everybody
else
now russia when you really look at
russia it's big on the map
but texas is twice as rich
as russia and has half the half the
people
if texas was an independent country it
would whip russia's ass
now it might take time for it to build
up a military force
but a modern military force does not
look like a 20th century
military force with millions of tanks
and [ __ ] millions of infantry
that shit's easy to destroy now and you
can destroy that [ __ ] cheap and easy
um a helicopter just a small group of
helicopters can destroy hundreds of
tanks in a night
you just can't use that [ __ ] anymore now
it's all that
that thinking all came out of world war
ii and it was
all going obsolete as world war ii ended
so the the generations of warfare have
gone
two generations since that you're now in
fifth generation warfare
which is lying your ass off
uh um that's one of the main weapons
confusing the enemy
driving the enemy insane getting the
enemy to kill itself or to fight itself
suing the enemy into oblivion
criticizing the enemy it's information
war
so yeah russia's russia will invade
ukraine it'll make quick
work of ukraine because ukraine mostly
won't it won't resist
um and uh the united states won't have a
response to it
uh we'll respond with harsh language
the united states is not in any position
in any position
to tell other countries how to handle
its business and what it can have and
what it cannot have
it's lost the it's lost the military
power to do that
and it's lost the moral authority to do
that
uh that's all from another era we're now
in a multi-polar world and it will
and it will and the polls will
multiply as time goes on because
centralized top-down control is now
technologically impossible
the world's going to look more and more
fractured and more and more tribal
it won't be top down it'll be more like
a network
it might even get to the point where the
the concept of a nation state
may not be viable might go down to
city-states
that might be a little bit more or ethno
states
that might be more tenable
in the future world
you know that's not me saying this this
has been a lot of think tanks are thing
are thinking this way that's why they're
trying to crack down so much it's the
last
gasp of an elite
of elites inside of a society trying to
maintain their power over something
that's just fragmenting
it won't work though okay let's see what
else is going on
well we do have to talk about death
proof at some point we're going to talk
about that okay
okay hey look i found it dj minnick says
you need full sleeve tattoos to be a
[ __ ]
to be a chef today and you need some
hair like guy fieri
yeah yeah
and his donkey sauce or whatever the
[ __ ] he calls it
yeah kyle says i can see jenny starting
to drift off yeah she doesn't like that
kind of stuff
well it's just i don't um he doesn't
like
he doesn't really guys like that stuff
women don't seem to like that kind of
stuff
do you have an asteroid in here for that
somewhere over there
somewhere that you spoke in this house
okay what are you gonna do stop me no
i don't really care the people that
wanted it before us you smoked
you know i breathe i just don't want you
just to get me to start smoking again
i'm gonna look at it and i'm going like
i don't think about him until i see him
well i only like to do it when i'm
drinking
yeah i know what i mean i noticed i got
hats here
i got many how many hats did you bring i
got four of them one for each level
i'm gonna start off with the beginning
level one level one
now and then level five might be
wigs it could be level six i run out of
hats
level six might be one of my wigs yeah
so we'll see if we'll get there i would
really like to see that
i wanna see what you look like with some
of the wigs on i i actually i was gonna
wear a wig tonight but then i forgot to
put the wig cap on before
the makeup and then i was like well [ __ ]
if i try to put the wig cap on now it'll
[ __ ] the makeup on my forehead up and
it's like it's this whole thing
somebody interesting how could the
united states collapse so soon we're too
young to go the way the romans exist you
don't know dude
i am history over and over again shows
the empire's only last 200 years and
that's how old the united states is
rome as rome as an empire really rome
only lasted about 200 years
it was i think 300 or maybe a couple
hundred years before that but it wasn't
the rome that you're thinking of it was
more like a bunch of greek city-states
rum lasted about 200. and then it split
into two
and then it slowly declined in one area
and then the eastern roman empire now
200 is about right and it's always the
same
uh corruption gets them corruption in
the ruling class
um something that's called uh
institutional senility
or civilizational senility is a problem
and the scamification of a of a
civilization usually has to do with
labor practices
in sourcing or outsourcing labor just
also uh massive quantities of unrest
veterans who didn't get what they were
promised that also happened in
in rome they weren't they weren't given
the land and the farms they were
promised
after they fought the damn war against
carthage
instead of giving them the land they
imported a bunch of germanic slaves
and in sourced the labor in terms of
slave labor and they had them running
those farms
because rich people invested in farmland
and a bunch of pissed off veterans
caused
unrest and that unrest kind of
reverberated throughout rome for about
80 years 60 to 80 years
and it was it became more and more
[ __ ] ridiculous a bunch of brand
circuses the inability to [ __ ]
defend borders uh slowly what ended up
happening to it was
uh through a long process of
colonization and semi-integration
rome lost its identity it didn't
wasn't destroyed it just faded away into
other things
it had no identity towards the end and
then the end of the wrong
roman period rome was just a city
and its money wasn't really worth
anything
phase one hat
trying to get me to wear your blue rig
well like i said you just have
enough drinks and maybe you will yeah
eastern rome lasted about a thousand
years after that
but you gotta also could be
some people are counting times of the
ottoman and the ottoman empire is that
and it was a little bit different
they kind of changed hands the power
dynamic changed a bit
um it was a theocracy and
you know it was it was a theocracy
basically it
it had weird characteristics
i'm not yeah i'm not sure yeah yeah
maybe it did last a thousand years but
i think there were different phases in
it egypt was the same way
they had three major kingdoms the middle
kingdom the old kingdom and the new
kingdom
not all that egyptian stuff was actually
the same civilization per se
it rebooted itself several times so i'd
had to really go
look at the eastern roman empire or the
byzantine empire and
its histories and see how many times it
actually rebooted and it probably
rebooted several times
but my history my knowledge of that
history isn't all that good
pokey's back there oh pokey's butt
what's up
making a cameo appearance yeah forrester
oh please don't please
don't please another problem is that
you're not dealing with the same
technological effects that you would
deal with today
please don't technology modern
technology has accelerated a lot of
stuff
and made a lot of traditional stuff
impossible no but you don't poke
no doubt no
[Laughter]
i know what you're thinking but don't
yeah
egyptians no pants yeah no pants well
notice the fourth throw down said the
problem with rome was together they
should have invented pants
please tell me that you romans didn't
wear pants either
please tell me that you're referring to
that mystery science theater sketch
where
they where uh they try to have a toga
party in ancient rome and everybody's
just like what's the big deal and
they're like oh yeah you idiots wear
tokens all the time so then they have a
pants party
and it's like really really exciting
because they've never seen pants before
that's the first thing i thought of i
don't know if that was just like a
coincidence or if you
actually did uh we're referring to that
towards the end of the roman period
um romans started to emulate germanic
peoples but they started wearing pants
pants and shirts that had sleeves on
them
and it was considered to be kind of
scandalous i was just gonna for a roman
to be wearing that [ __ ] because that was
barbarian stuff and then they were
[ __ ]
growing beards you know and you were
kind of like dude you're growing a beard
like a [ __ ] german what that was
wrong with you oh my god do you think
you're a dizzy top or whatever and then
dudes would start showing up with
saddles
and they were like dude you're wearing a
saddle you got a saddle on that horse
what the [ __ ]
because the robins didn't have saddles
they didn't they they would kind of like
would not wear it they wore a saddle pad
they
used saddle pads but we like our balls
touching the horses like that
and a lot of that [ __ ] came from them
fighting the germans
fighting the germans and fighting the
gauls over time you know
the roman roman legionnaires noticed
that they had better [ __ ]
yeah they had much better technology
they had better stuff when it came to
horses you know saddles and pants
[ __ ] might need some pants it gets cold
as hell you know
never thought of pants there's like a
lot of a lot of that roman statuary and
the rump
it's got to be propaganda because
they're showing
romans fighting germans and some of
these like frescoes that they have
in jar in germanic areas fighting them
and they're dressed like roman soldiers
you know [ __ ] saddles and
no pants just a skirt and any
you know they weren't wearing that [ __ ]
it was cold as [ __ ] they had they were
probably dressed just like the germans
well if they were smart there they were
smart they would you know sit there it
was like i have this tiny mini skirt on
it
like [ __ ] freezing god damn it yeah
and the balls are retreating up into my
[ __ ] cabin and they were out there
for years
deployed fighting these people all right
and local merchants were selling had to
be selling them [ __ ]
you know what i mean i'm sure they
weren't getting regular resupply from
rome they probably just bought stuff
or took stuff while they were there so
they probably you probably really
couldn't
tell them apart from romans other than
the standard from germans other than the
standards they were carrying and
probably maybe some of the weapons and
maybe like the colors of things that
they wore
but i guarantee those statues don't
represent the way they looked when they
were in combat
against germans and you know in foreign
in germania
it couldn't be now they could you
couldn't survive a winner in those
clothes
yeah you'd be a little roman [ __ ]
dead yeah german says i was confused as
pants or underwear in the uk yeah when
they say when they say pants over there
they usually mean like
like yeah yeah it's like creeps yeah
i've also heard them called why fronts
so like little white yeah
they say trousers jeans or pants
you know pants i've got legs
i've got legs on pants pantaloons yeah
[Laughter]
although they still say panties over
here although i try not to say that
because i hate that [ __ ]
word it just
it sounds dirty even though it's not
dirty you know what i'm saying yeah
i was gonna say something but i forgot
because i don't
remember oh i miss pookie she'll
probably be back she's in here somewhere
yeah she jumped up on the desk back
there and was like farting around she's
like well please i want to run across
the laptop
and mess everything up all right so um
where's death proof
it's right here yeah somebody says death
proof we had it written down you
remember who said his death proof
i did have it written down but i didn't
remember where you get the piece of
paper
a patron sent us death proof it was good
i liked it i'd never seen it
um interesting i saw it in back in the
theater when it came out
in 2007 it was originally a
double feature with robert rodriguez's
planet terror and it was all one big
movie called grindhouse
and you went and watched it and then
there was like trailers for fake movies
even though some of the trailers ended
up becoming real movies later on
like uh you know machete yeah machete
yeah
uh that was started out as a fake
trailer on that uh hobo with shotgun
that also started out as a fake trailer
on that and it subsequently became a
real movie
um but yeah so so it was kind of like
you guys see those two
i got you i've seen i've seen uh i've
seen machete i don't think i've seen
hobo with a shotgun though
yeah well look we'll do a full review on
this later but we're just mentioning it
we'll make sure we give the person
credit who get it who sent that to us
it's just been so long and
so many people have sent us stuff i got
a whole pile of [ __ ] we have to go
through
well and like i said that's why we're
just going to start talking about them
either on here or on
the matinee live streams because we have
somebody that we have to catch up on
yeah but it was a good flick crustle was
in it
plays a serial killer who's in this damn
car he's [ __ ]
running down women and trying to kill
him in different ways with his car
yeah killing him with his car dealing
with his car i mean
the thing about this okay so the version
that's on here is uh actually the
extended version so it's like 27 minutes
longer i think than the one that i saw
in the theater
so i actually like i said i saw in the
theater so i had never seen this version
before
i think the stuff that was at it was
mostly just um you know conversations
and
[ __ ] like that but um it was just i had
forgotten how good this was because
honestly i think the first time when i
saw grindhouse in the theater
i don't know i liked both um i liked
both halves of it because planet terror
is really good too but i haven't seen
that in a while
and then i think i don't know i think i
slightly liked planet terror better but
now i think i may be like death proof
better
it's like yeah it's kind of like i don't
know i really like the way it's it's
almost kind of like two movies in one
because like the first part of it is
almost kind of like a slasher film
and then the second part of it is like a
car chase movie yeah
like it's kind of like you know
vanishing point obviously because they
mentioned that a bunch of times but it's
also kind of like faster pussycat kill
kill
it's kind of like that it's a shot like
it's a 70s
[ __ ] cheap 70s low budget flick
on purpose it's got like grainy colored
great grainy quality films what it looks
like and then later it kind of clears it
goes black and white and then after that
it clears up
it's kind of weird how the movie
progresses
it's like three movies yeah like i said
it's almost like three chapters of a
book and they're all look
different yeah and yeah i'm sure he did
that deliberately and well the
interesting thing about this is that
quentin tarantino
um you can tell like obviously he's
super super
into exploitation movies uh and he's
really enthusiastic about it so you can
tell
how much how excited he was to make a
movie like this like him and robert
rodriguez and it was gonna be like this
big
thing and it's like oh it's gonna be
like a double feature like back in the
old days when you went to
you know this sleazy 42nd street theater
and you would see a double feature of
like these exploitation films with all
these like [ __ ] crazy trailers in
between
so it's like it's really cool that they
wanted to replicate that experience but
it really seems like you didn't do very
well you know what i mean
if i feel like it didn't i don't know
audiences just didn't really respond to
it and i think a lot of people think
that it's
his worst movie and even he says it's
his worst movie even though
he's like well it's still awesome and if
that's like my worst one which is worth
which is worth moving death proof
no no he's saying that some people
thought that no yeah yeah yeah it's not
no that's one of these better ones yeah
i think so too
i really really like i mean i really
like all the character [ __ ] i like all
the conversations that they have i like
all that [ __ ]
the world war ii one i thought it sucked
pretty bad
and glory is bad yeah i thought i
thought it sucked um
just i don't find nazis funny i don't
even i don't even find
i don't even find like [ __ ] making fun
of them funny you know what i mean i
even though i do like like [ __ ]
journey you know [ __ ]
what was it [ __ ] uh what was that one
second that was a good move oh
[ __ ] i have no idea what you're talking
about the nazis at the center of the
earth oh right right yeah
but that had there was a reason why i
liked that one
okay but no i just don't like making a
light of that kind of [ __ ]
and [ __ ] and i don't like the
distortions that they do for humor
because i think it
it kind of takes a [ __ ] serious issue
and distorts it
into something like it's not either it's
not a threat or
they're trying to make it in something
that it wasn't you have to kind of
i think it's it's more healthy to kind
of accurately present what that was all
about and
why that happened so you know you can
kind of
you can accurately spot it what it is
if that would ever happen again because
that's
that theme goes throughout all cultures
and it kind of reemerges over time
every time it comes back it's it's
different
but it is that same idea it's kind of
this
you have to understand the third reich
saw themselves as a bunch of do-gooders
they thought they were doing the right
thing say these weren't guys that
thought that they were doing the bad
thing they thought they were doing the
right thing well nobody thinks they're
doing it yeah
nobody thinks they're doing that yeah
and that's the [ __ ] key
all right these guys aren't running
around thinking well we're the bad guys
no they thought they were the good guys
they thought they were wiping out the
bad guys
so you got to be careful man what was
that was it uh mitchell and webb that uh
that comedy team that did the that did
not like nazis
are we the baddies like they were just
realizing it
yeah that's right i don't remember that
it's really easy to lose sight
you know what i mean [ __ ] warfare is
about
basically dehumanizing an enemy for one
reason
or another and then acting on it and
everybody kind of does it
um and then they say well they were
killing civilians well everybody killed
civilians in warfare we dropped all
these [ __ ] damn bombs
on japanese civilians i think we killed
six million of them no more six minutes
it was
it was 40 cities that we bombed i think
it was like
close to 63 million
civilian casualties i think i think
that's what it was
[ __ ] that's uh you know unprecedented
you know
but for some reason in history we didn't
go down like the nazis
because we wrote the history not to say
that we were bad
everybody thinks they're good when
they're doing that kind of stuff
um and then we did the same things to
the germans because they were german
and they were nazis so you go down
anywhere burn down their [ __ ] cities
kill all their women and children
see modern warfare they're always
talking about well we gotta
we gotta keep it to military targets one
military fighting another military
you'll never really win a war that way
not a real war
you might win an argument that way but
no
[ __ ] traditionally what you did what
and this goes back thousands of years
an army defeated another army so they
could get around them and get to those
civilians
for one reason or another either to kill
them or to capture them and
sell them into slavery that's what most
civilizations did
um and it's because you're holding the
people
personally responsible for what their
government did
it says your government wage war on us
or they lost against us
or they did this or that so now you
belong to us
you're going to do what we say because
if you don't do that they'll just elect
another leader that's just like the last
one
it'll be kind of like a forever kind of
war thing
no decisive action okay here here i'm
going to cut right to the
chase traditional warfare was genocide
you went right towards the enemy's
civilian population and you annihilated
their culture
the culture itself you toppled their
gods and their statues and burned their
cities down and killed all their people
and then they sewed the [ __ ] ground
with salt so they would never come back
it was extremely brutal you this is this
is talked about in all these movies that
we talk about like
like apocalypse now how modern
armies try to sip make war civilized how
can you civilize a war
you can't you know i think colonel kurtz
said it the best in apocalypse now
because generals tell pilots that it's
immoral if they write [ __ ] on their
airplanes but then they'll tell them to
go out and drop
fire on little children
you know so you can't you can't moralize
war
war
itself is immoral if you look at it
through moralistic
lens uh
i'm having a problem doing that because
actually the immoral and the psychopaths
all rise to the top of society and
they're running the [ __ ] show it's
like they have an evolutionary
advantage over everybody else we're
entrapped into this system of good and
evil that they put on us that we
see we see things through the light of
good and right and wrong and good and
evil
but the people that rule this earth and
the people who
in our ruling class and then the ones
above it
you know these oligarchs and stuff
people that own the world they don't
have that problem i'm gonna call it a
problem
they don't care they just see us as
things
and that's the truth
so they're the ones that [ __ ] make
all that [ __ ] happen
so you know i'm just so i'm just a
[ __ ]
little man at home with a [ __ ] jerk
all right i'm just observing it and
telling you what i see
yeah i think it's all bad okay
yeah now we're uh debating whether kill
bill i like to kill bill um
true romance i have not seen in a long
time i remember really liking it the
first time i saw it he just wrote that
right not directed it
um yeah i'd agree that his best movie is
once upon a time
in hollywood uh but
i don't you know it's just there's
something i really really liked like i
said i really liked
that him and robert rodriguez went like
the whole
hog into we're gonna replicate a 70s
grindhouse experience
in film form they didn't give a [ __ ] if
it did well or not
they were just excited about it and they
loved exploitation films and they wanted
to recapture that
now they're you know okay so i was
watching this one thing
where somebody was uh talking about
death proof and they were kind of
talking about
quentin tarantino and how i mean quentin
tarantino is very very
anti uh digital he does not like cgi he
doesn't like
uh he doesn't like movies shot on
digital he likes to shoot on film
um you know which is obviously becoming
more increasingly more difficult
nowadays
so a lot of people have pointed out that
the character of stuntman mike
in death proof is kind of like his
avatar i guess because you know the
scene with him talking about like all
the
tv shows that he was in and like all
these actors that he worked with
and all the young girls at the bar like
don't know who the [ __ ] he's talking
about
um you know and and him being almost
kind of like kurt russell's character
kind of being
like a like a throwback you know what i
mean to like old hollywood and
everybody kind of making fun of what he
looked like somebody like that eli roth
in there calling him stroker ace
and all this other kind of [ __ ] which i
thought was really funny
but um i don't know but the guy that
made the video was pointing out he's
like you know that's cool and everything
if that's what you want to do you know
he wants to do real stunts like they did
in this movie
um but they're like on the other side of
the coin
something that we talk about a lot too
is that digital uh
technology has made it much easier for
like the little guy
to make movies for much more cheaply
than you would have been able to make
them
in the past like i get where tarantino
is coming from
you know what i mean it's like you know
there used to be a craft involved
but back in the old days you know he's
kind of
championing the little guy back then
making these cheap ass exploitation
movies
but that's what people do nowadays it's
just if we
if you had to like pay for all this
[ __ ] expensive equipment
you wouldn't be able to do it like so
digital kind of
has made it i don't like cgi that much
either
to be honest with you because it makes
everything too easy and fake looking
uh so i get that but i'm not averse to
digital technology as a whole like in
filmmaking or anything like that because
you can do
it's just a tool you can do anything
with it but i do
you know i do appreciate that he likes a
certain aesthetic like a throwback
aesthetic kind of look and that's what
he wanted to do so we wanted to shoot it
on film and show like that
but you know i you know what somebody
mentioned um
django and i have not seen i think
that's the only tarantino movie i
haven't seen yet
now that i'm thinking about it i've seen
jackie brown yeah yeah yeah i saw jackie
brown so i think that might be the only
one that i haven't seen
um but there's a few that i haven't seen
i liked the hateful eight as well but
there's some that i haven't seen in a
long time
but for me i think his best movies is
still but
well once a final time in hollywood i
think it was his best one
yeah me too tonally i think that's
that's his best one
um i did like uh reservoir dogs yeah i
did as well
um he wrote the story a true romance
and but didn't direct it i like true
romance
a lot of his stuff okay like pulp
fiction
in those days i liked it it's i can go
back and
i like certain scenes of it
but you kind of go back and look at it
and it's just it was kind of overhyped
at the time
but like i said it was a movie of its
time
a lot of his stuff is just kind of hit
or miss he's got a [ __ ] weird foot
fetish
well everybody everybody knows that yeah
it gets
worse as he as he get goes off into it
you know
and death proof has a lot of feet yeah
man there's a lot of feet
and even there's that one scene where
kurt russell comes and essentially like
licks that licks that girl's toe yeah
feet are not good looking even if you
got pretty feet those [ __ ] are ugly
okay feet are not good i don't like feet
well you know everyone's different yeah
i don't like feet either i like feet it
doesn't bother me though
yeah it's just to me it's just kind of
funny because i'm like oh there's feet
again
very rarely have i seen a feet and i say
that you see he has cute feet
but that lies grantharis knows i'm
talking that's like back when we were in
high school grab there's
some girls we were dating they had cute
feet because they were young
yeah and they were you know but as
people get older and their [ __ ]
feet get all [ __ ] tough and [ __ ]
gnarly and
being in shoes all especially women's
shoes that [ __ ] push them
they had this [ __ ] real pointed
little [ __ ] toes and those little
[ __ ]
shoes that you all used to wear you know
what i mean i didn't [ __ ] that some
women used to work
remember your friend where this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
one she moved away yeah yeah yeah her
name was jen yeah
i don't know how she crammed those
[ __ ] feet she was a big girl and she
crammed
his feet her feet into these tiny little
[ __ ] shoes
little high-heeled shoes and walk around
it's as big as she was with these little
bitty shoes doing the exactly opposite
if you're a big girl you don't want
little shoes you want big shoes try to
even that [ __ ] out
try to even that [ __ ] yeah you want to
disperse the weight too
it just looked [ __ ] ridiculous look
like she's walking around little hooves
you know and it's just i never really
like those shoes because it always
seemed like
you know it's kind of like you know you
want shoes that are going to like make
your
make your legs and [ __ ] look good but
you also don't want to wear shoes that
you're just going to be [ __ ] dying at
the end of the night and then you got to
be that
drunk girl carrying your shoes and
walking off down the filthy streets in
your bare feet
nobody wants to do nobody wants to be
that girl most most people
better than the one puking in the gutter
i guess but not by much
most people have [ __ ] busted ass
looking feet busted up looking [ __ ]
toast
well that's what you're on all the time
you're on your feet every single day
yeah and you know most
i would say half the damn women above
over the age of 35 got some busted ass
looking look at feet
and for different you know if you're
skinny you got these gnarly little
[ __ ]
skinny looking [ __ ] just great i want
to talk about it he has the opposite of
a foot fetish
i have like foot revulsion tammy says
only babies have cute feet yeah
babies and teenage little teenage girls
have cute feet my feet aren't that bad
no they're okay they're okay that's as
feet go yeah you're a little bit
flat-footed
well yeah i've always been flat yeah
your arches are a little bit you know
yeah some people have that but yeah
i've had that my whole life as much as i
can remember so yeah i am flat-footed
but that's about it
the um i just yeah just feet are not an
attractive
thing but you know i don't understand
why but you know what's cool though
in uh death proof it's almost kind of
like he's like
feet feet like all the time but then he
almost kind of like subverts it
in that big [ __ ] wreck you know what
i mean like in the middle where uh where
kurt russell kills the first
car load of girls and like they're just
[ __ ] everywhere and that one girl
has one her one of her legs with her
bare foot sticking out the window
and it cuts her whole [ __ ] leg off
and then the leg goes flying like
bouncing on the road
that's actually one of the best like
[ __ ] car accidents ever put on
[ __ ]
film it was so so good like and then the
tire going over the girl's face and like
it's [ __ ] great grandpa says some
cute girls and trenton back in 1987.
that's for sure because just to wherever
we came up with some [ __ ]
we came up with with a good bet with a
good batch although gramsci
said i see some of their photos on
facebook now time can be one cruel [ __ ]
yes it is there's a few of them held out
though
there's a few of them that have held out
christy watson still looks cute as hell
oh there's mary lynn still looks pretty
cute
uh you know that's all i say
you like talking about actual people
yeah like hopefully they're not like
watching i'm not gonna talk about the
people who weren't aren't cute
that's why i was gonna say that one was
[ __ ] up
it's like what if some girl that went to
high school with leona's like really
upset about it because she had like a
disease or something yeah
like then she was watching and she was
like great yeah like then somebody's
still like thinking about ugly i am all
these years later
yeah dudes are so mean
[Laughter]
well it's just you know
that's all i'm gonna say it's just you
know life
it's life you know what i mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] happens to people
yeah not everybody lives the same life
not the same
the same things don't happen to
everybody else no
people exactly and then people do not
react
to that all the same way you know
somebody could
be dealt a good hand early on and then
something bad happens to them and they
can't shake out of it and all of a
sudden they just kind of go downhill
because they couldn't recover well yeah
i mean like i said
you know some people think [ __ ] get
in accidents or get diseases or
something like that and they can't
you know that's the only part of it no
i'm just saying that i'm just saying
using that as an example a lot of it's
psychological
a lot of it's psychological i've noticed
that's
people that stay put their whole lives
tend
to not do as well over time and i don't
know if it's some kind of a psychologist
psychology because they're not being
stimulated enough
it's like they peek out at high school
and then it's just a gradual decline of
[ __ ] mundane work
in faceless nameless jobs in a certain
area
and the problem is is that
well what me and granters were talking
about is that we were in
a very middle-class
predominantly white area at that time
that was all being supported by a car
industry that vanished
if you stayed there there wasn't gonna
be much you could there wasn't gonna be
much economic growth for you you had to
leave
or you had to find something in local
government like being a cop or whatever
then you could you could make a good
living but that whole area is being
supported by general motors
and ford and once that dwindled that was
the end of that
i mean it's that's still there but it
just didn't have the optimism
that that area used to have you know
when we grew up there was like something
out of damn back to the future
you know looking like somebody you
expect to see marty mcfly over there you
know with this [ __ ]
puppy with his time machine
[Laughter]
they're building the new they're
building the new housing complex and
his girlfriend gonna move in there and
then in the alternate timeline it's a
[ __ ] ghetto
what's his name biff took over built
that casino
built a casino and turned it into a
ghetto which that doesn't happen
mississippi [ __ ] on gulf coast built
casinos and it's a little
mini las vegas that's nice but
you know i think it might had some dude
with a bunch of organized crime that
biff was doing
yeah i think it was more that was
right i don't think it was the fact that
it was a casino casino was just kind of
shorthand for
kind of sleazy business yeah because
it's not like he couldn't open
you know a brothel because that would be
illegal so
they're kind of like well we'll say
casino and then yeah he'll support the
brothels because
it's like that'll spring up next to the
casinos and [ __ ] like that
yeah gadget3 says i'm trying to [ __ ]
eat here [ __ ] off with the feet
um oracle said james cameron's rather
fond of feet too is he really i never
noticed that
yeah now i'm gonna have to like look out
next time i watch a james cameron movie
grantor says we went to the same church
as christie in trenton she was always a
cutie
and then he goes uh
said something earlier he said but we
were talking about some people
not doing well over time and he said
well booze and processed
food doesn't help much either yeah trail
yeah but like i said i you know i i
drink a lot but in my defense
i didn't start drinking until i was like
in my late 30s so i figure i can i got
some time to catch up
yeah i was talking to another guy when
you
if as long as you don't burn up all that
gas in your tank early you can get away
with a lot
that's what i that's what i figured yeah
you can get away with a lot after 50.
because i seriously did not drink hardly
at all until i was like in my
mid to late 30s it's just
i'm i'm really getting off into the damn
biotech
and how [ __ ] how hormone hormone
therapies and how certain drugs work
on the human body and looking at what
happens to people as they age and
[ __ ] do all these things you know
what i mean
over history too looking at what jack
o'lane did and some of the guys from
back in the 70s
another couple decades it doesn't matter
if [ __ ]
the united states breaks apart into a
million pieces or whatever the
the end of the world comes technology
will continue to advance
jenny now we're talking about that so
that's something that
i know some of you might be worried
about what's going on don't worry about
government
i've been through governments that
collapsed already when i was living in
brazil
it doesn't affect the technology
technology continues to move forward
in a couple decades man they're going to
have some [ __ ] some biotechnology out
there and [ __ ]
they're going to reach singularity and
computer technology would be able to do
stuff like
like something out of them like
something out of [ __ ] what was that
scientology movie we were looking at uh
we're talking about
uh what battlefield earth battlefield
earth
where they can access the mind through
the [ __ ] retina of your eye
you know uh download your consciousness
take it out of your brain and put it
into a damn
internet like heaven like see that's
what i'm waiting for
and then you can come out of that
internet wirelessly and go into
robotic bodies that are like cars or
airplanes yeah i want to do that
or you could be an airplane or you could
be a car you can be a [ __ ] robot
you could be a sex robot you could be
whatever you want at any time
or you could stay inside the internet
have just internet sex
whatever that is it feels like real like
a virtual reality
and then you can be transhuman where you
could be any kind of human you want
you know [ __ ] you could even be an
animal or a mixture of humans an
animal so your your body is just an
avatar in there
you know for some people style it
however you want to be a [ __ ] dragon
you know something just whatever for
some reason i thought of that cartoon
from like the 70s or 80s called animal
olympics
yeah do you remember that one with it
and it was like half it was it was
people that were like half animal they
were animals but they were like
they ran around on two legs like he did
i don't know i never seen it
yeah it was good now i have to like look
at that oh god
it must have been 80s that's probably
earlier it's probably in the army i
don't know i didn't see it
but maybe it was earlier in brazil
probably
but the uh grant there's hammer says you
look great jenny well thank you it's all
the beer the girls in trenton drank that
wrecked them
see i'm not a big bee i'm not a big beer
fan yeah
the only time i ever drink beer is if
we're at a place that doesn't have a
full liquor license and that's
it's either beer or nothing then i'll
have a beer or two but other than that
i'm not a big fan of it
values and psychology has a lot to do
with it and knowledge
i mean a lot of people didn't weren't
really grab this man
think of the [ __ ] that we used to eat up
at [ __ ] denny's when we were kids
yeah you go to daddy's and eat some [ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] mozzarella
take some moon over my hammy yeah yeah
deep fried
chicken fried steak patty with some
[ __ ] gravy
mashed potatoes and gravy on the side
okay see even i never ate then they
would like
pour a big ladle of them melted cheese
on the top of it
some people just stayed eating all that
stuff and it's directly from
cisco you know and it's basically fast
food
yeah not a lot of good nutrition low in
protein high in carbohydrates high
fat and um it
tastes good i guess you don't have real
you know i mean if that's all you got
you're like yeah
this is good honestly if i'm going to
denny's i'm getting a breakfast
because i i don't trust any of their
other people yeah so although some of
their skillets
are okay well actually they have some
breakfast things a little i don't know
i've been there in years and years but
tina shows up what's up t
they used to have a skillet scramble
which was like eggs and peppers and
onions so it's like fairly healthy and
it was just kind of all like
made in a skillet and it was actually
like pretty tasty it might have been
like some
little potatoes in there too but i can't
remember tea we already talked about
death proof that we we're off that now
well we didn't talk about it that much
because yeah we could talk about it we
we kept going off
tom's on soap but go ahead and check out
go check out taylor you do you do get on
i get on a soapbox while i've been
drinking
not that much look i'm still at level
one
he's still that's what i mean he's still
got his level one hat on i got a lot
more
[ __ ] it i'm going to level two okay
going to level two def con
two on the level two ranger patrol cap
going on
range wake me up when you get ready for
patrol when you get to the lady wigs
later wigs probably like level five or
six all right after this one
after this one i got the [ __ ] special
forces
tiger stripe booty cap
that's makes you that's when i'm at
sexual tyrannosaur level
and then the last hat is this one
this is my [ __ ] um this hat is
straight up [ __ ] redneck
it's straight redness it's so you'll put
it on and we won't be able to see you
the only thing
yeah i'll vanish the only thing i'm
missing is like a [ __ ] caterpillar
i'll edit you out like at that point
i'll be like that works
i'm gonna need a big old [ __ ]
caterpillar [ __ ] caterpillar or john
deere on there
then you need some chaw yeah i'd be
redneck as [ __ ]
oh my gosh sexy as [ __ ] lady wigs and
corsets okay the black girls love it
i keep telling him i kept telling him i
was we went to memento mori on monday
night
and i kept telling him to i'm like one
of these days i'm going to make you come
to this place with a [ __ ] wig and
high-heeled boots and a corset and [ __ ]
like that
you'll see you'll see the price we pay
is it almost time for you to get another
uh get another drink yeah because my
shit's empty okay look look at that
you're not on the ball
that's pretty much the end of the
pineapple juice so we gotta flip over to
orange juice that's fine i can give you
um what flavor is it listen let me
rattle it off i'll give you 50 50 bar or
i could give you um
orange cupcake um lunch cupcakes
have i had an orange cupcake no i had it
it was good all right let me try that
tastes like those
hostess orange cupcakes yeah i know what
you're talking about i mean you know i'm
not a huge fan of those but it's
probably pretty good
i mean that uh that uh pinnacle cake
body is actually
actually pretty good yeah defcon one
becomes pure energy that's right that's
right yes
you're talking about me putting on a
damn curly wig see
it's everyone's dream man no that's
that's when i remember michael caine
michael caine from the hand if i put
that wig on
they love that [ __ ] wig because it's
hilarious if i put that wig on i got to
be wearing that [ __ ] blue jumpsuit
yeah yeah although is it now can we
can we establish fact cause that was a
willy wonka wig was it yeah it was
really walkable
that's what i felt like well because
when we were looking for the halloween
costumes
and i was trying to help him find a wig
and i was like dude just get the willy
wonka wig because their hair was almost
exactly the same
not from the giant the shitty jumping up
one from the original woman jean wilde
that's in there in it yeah all the wigs
are in there
i specifically look i bought a bunch of
wigs and i even bought
those like plastic they're really nice
they're like these plastic hangers that
go like that and they have like a little
wig stand on them so you can hang them
in your closet and you can have them
they don't get all [ __ ] up
if i put that wig on without that blue
job suit
and just wear it and start relaxing and
forget that i have it on
i become robert plant from [ __ ] like
that
i do i become robert the levee breaks
and then
they've got no place hold on
oh my god yeah tom can totally recycle
that wig for next halloween
you could do wonka or you could be
richard simmons oh my god that'd be
funny
he's not chubby enough to be richard
simmons although i would oh
willy wonka would actually be really
good you can get like a purple velvet
suit and like a top hat
i just realized so mannequins
the the horror themed club in downtown
orlando that are uh friend big tom owns
uh i just did a poster if they're doing
a halfway to halloween party
is it this i think it's not i don't
think it's this friday i think it's next
friday
so i'm like well [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i'm
gonna have to like come up with a
costume
like really quick you know what i mean i
hate having to do that
you know i don't like just doing if i'm
going to do a costume i don't want to go
like i want to go all out with the [ __ ]
i want it to look as
authentic as possible um so i'd like to
have every little detail right
i mean i was really mad like the one
that i you know the one that i did for
the show
last halloween like amy from fright
night i like how that came out but
i was kind of pissed that like the mouth
that i was trying to do like didn't
because i had um like an appliance like
for the mouth and it didn't work out it
wouldn't stay
it was like i couldn't match the color
to my skin color and it was getting to
be a pain so i just kind of like drew it
on sloppily like at the last minute
and it looked okay like on screen but i
was like
yeah it wasn't as good as i wanted but
i don't know i like to have like a long
lead time to do a halloween costume
because i hate having to come up with
[ __ ] like
just on the and i like to do something
that
that a lot of people don't do you know
what i mean because tom's always like
well no one's gonna know who that is i'm
like i don't give a [ __ ] i'll know who
it is
and it's like and i will be happy about
it it's not all about what other people
think about it i just want one that i
like you know
and i also don't i don't like joke
costumes
and i'm trying to think of like all the
[ __ ]
you know what after all this time i
think we went to a
halloween party at ibarr [ __ ] man it was
probably like
four or five years ago now that i'm
thinking of it
and the costume that i still remember
the best
was there was a group of three people i
don't know if it was girls or guys
because
you know you couldn't see them but they
dressed like
if you guys remember the the yip aliens
from
sesame street the ones with like the
little thing they were all furry and
then they just went yeah
there was like three of them and they
all dressed like those it was so
awesome and they were like full body and
they just went around like that all
night
thank you i don't know who they were
because they didn't take their costumes
off
and they didn't talk but yeah they
looked super cool
what do you tell mom halloween costumes
oh okay
because i was saying that i don't think
it's this friday but the next friday
mannequins is having a halfway to
halloween parties they're having a
costume contest
and i was like i hate having to like be
rushed into thinking of like a halloween
guy
i posted all kinds of pictures of you
lately from all kinds of hot [ __ ]
that you were wearing some hot [ __ ]
she's in there [ __ ] in the bathroom
sitting we're not doing her [ __ ]
makeup no i was putting i was putting my
lee press on now yeah my my nails see i
got these
i got a whole bunch of different seasons
are green yeah but i got like a whole it
was like 120 different ones and it's
like all different colors and [ __ ]
i'm creeping up back there [ __ ]
trying to get i know he's creeping up
trying to get pictures of my ass trying
to get it yeah
and i'm like i'm putting my nails on god
damn it yeah i'm gonna show you and he's
taking pictures of me with glasses and
stuff i mean i just you guys see me with
glasses all the time because i can't
[ __ ]
yeah that's my best dog you already have
fluency
that's yeah i love those horns
yeah but they don't it's there it's a
little too big for my head because i
guess i have a small head
so i really have to watch because if i
do my head like that they'll
fall off you know what i mean and that's
embarrassing when that's about taking
pictures like that
[ __ ] yeah and he's like look boobs
elsa says your bathroom looks huge it is
it is well the
the uh the master suite in this house
is actually quite large because we have
like a it's a really big huge
because there's the bedroom part like
with the bed and then
i didn't even see that one yeah you're
doing your um you're in the mirror what
the hell was i doing
fixing your hair oh okay cause i'm like
i look like i'm going like whoa yeah and
then i can't remember
why i can't remember why i was looking
like that specifically yeah
look how good that blue wig looks on you
i know
i think that's my might be my favorite
one of all i wore the i wore the red one
uh on monday i like that one too
real thin well that's always a good
thing yeah because it covers up all this
little baby fat [ __ ] no even when it
doesn't
yeah it's just something about what are
you doing polk she didn't want me
posting that i thought that was a good
picture i don't like that picture but
and then you show it i'll show it anyway
i didn't post it because he doesn't give
a [ __ ] what i say
but yeah so so the bedroom has like the
the bed area and then there's like a
little
like a little alcove kind of with like a
window and you know you could put like a
couch and [ __ ] over there if you wanted
to
and then the only thing i don't like
about the about the master suite is that
there's no door between the bedroom
and the big part of the bathroom
you know what i mean because we have
there's a tub like a garden tub and then
there's like a stand-up shower
and then there's like a big long sink in
a mirror and like the the toilet is like
in its own little
thing that you can obviously you can
close that off and then there's like
on the other side of that is a walk-in
closet but there's no door between
you know where the sink and the shower
and the tub are and the bath
in the bedroom it's just like an arch
you know what i mean
yeah so it's kind of like dylan's asking
you what about a sexy version
of the mummy i thought about doing that
um i've done
i've done cleopatra once you must have
listened like years and years
because i was talking about that on the
show the other day that the girl that
played the mommy in that damn
movie with tom cruise i thought she
looked [ __ ] great did she look cute
in that
yeah that yeah that might be a cool
outfit that might be a good outfit what
are you doing
that is not outside if you're sitting
in the closet she's looking at you like
but can i can i check
she's been in there before i don't know
why she forgot i don't understand what
side the closet opens on so sliding door
she thinks it opens from the middle in
the middle it doesn't because she's
always like scratching like in the
middle
she's just kind of like why would it
open daddy with the phone yeah she's
crazy
and i think she even though she's been
in there before i kind of feel like
she's always expecting that to be like
another outside like i said it's just
like it goes somewhere else
it's just like beijing trying to get in
the dishwasher yeah try to get a
dishwasher
she thinks the dishwasher goes outside
it's ridiculous
when we first moved to this house
because
the house has it's kind of like it's
almost kind of like u-shaped
you know what i mean so it's like so for
the master bedroom there's a sliding
glass door and then in the living room
on the other side like that there's a
sliding glass door
and then in the middle there's like a
foyer type area and that has just like
double doors that open like that which
we never open like onto the
porch onto the back porch and for a long
time when we first moved
in beijing thought that each door went
to a separate outside
yeah she had to check each one yeah
every door went to another outside the
same outside it kind of blew her mind
like because she kept like freaking out
why are there so many doors
she'd be like well you know it's just
kind of like
i don't i don't know if they grasp the
fact that like all the outside is like
connected
yeah because even now now because even
now like pookie will be
she'll scratch at the sliding glass door
in the master bedroom
and then you go over there to open it
she's like no no i want to go out the
front door because she wants to sit on
the front porch
in the front bushes she doesn't want to
sit on the back porch
in the little garden it's actually the
only time i've seen bathrooms like that
in the kind of hotel rooms that have
mirror-lined
jacuzzis and heart-shaped beds yeah
it does kind of look like that it does
kind of look like that i will say it's
cool like having a big
huge area like that but it is a [ __ ] to
clean and it takes for
ever yeah and this is pretty average
that's common for uh like the newer
florida houses well the house yeah and
they're all like this yeah and the ones
they build around here
like they all have those bases it's
nothing special the mansions up the
street are [ __ ]
five times that and they got several of
them
this house has three bathrooms that's
the master bathroom it has two
junior bathrooms yeah those are just
yeah but um um the master bathroom
is a bathroom there's no toilet in it
yeah just bath and a shower and that
mirror
yeah the toilet is in another room it's
in its own own little closet kind of
so you can have two people in there
doing you know taking
putting on makeup taking bath shower or
whatever and then you're not you know
taking a dump in front of you
that shit's got class you know it's not
like that you know
[Laughter]
then you come out of there and leave the
fan on there because i'll be like hey
jenny
i'm in the bathroom yes i know what
is it where is it i'm in the bathroom
well because when the fan's on i can't
see you're here to talk
no i can't hear you that's what it is
all right because
you know when you have you know you go
in and you just turn the light and the
fan on
just you know automatically right
because they're right next to each other
and so like if you're always trying he's
like because honestly he's
it's kind of like having a kid because
they kind of like you you can't go to
the bathroom it's like if they have to
ask you something he's got to ask you
like right now
and you know you're sitting in the
bathroom and then he's like where's that
thing and the thing i'm like dude
yeah i'll be out in a moment just yeah
calm down i can't hear what you're
saying anyway because the fan
derma says i pay a fortune to run an
apartment the size of the cupboard here
in london oh yeah
yeah but that's on you you decided to
live there
i mean i decided to live in boston same
[ __ ] thing
boston [ __ ] seven eight hundred
dollars a month yeah i mean
one bedroom is at a premium yeah 700
bucks a month here in [ __ ] florida
you can get a [ __ ] big house it'll be
an older house but it can get a big
house
with a [ __ ] lawn and you gotta
[ __ ] buy a damn [ __ ] ride on lawn
mower to [ __ ] cut the grass and
yeah suburban life in the united states
and
rural rural living in the united states
is [ __ ]
far superior to city life well the thing
about you are [ __ ]
rich unless you're filthy rich and
here's the thing
we have friends who their their families
are filthy rich like that
they have [ __ ] new york apartments
and
new york homes and [ __ ] but they have
homes here too they have homes
everywhere
so a lot of people if you can afford to
live real well in new york you can also
afford to live real well
in a bunch of other different states at
the same time
so it's it's insane where it actually
works see it wasn't outside wasn't pokey
she came out and she's like well that
was disappointing
yeah nothing in there poop
i will say though that if you don't i
mean because some people don't really
like doing yard work i certainly don't
um and the thing about it too is that
our neighborhood you know we have an hoa
which a lot of the nicer neighborhoods
do
make you paint your house and everything
and yeah you have to paint your house
they only have certain approved colors
uh you have to keep your grass mode so
we ended up paying
we got launch service we have a lawn
service because because when you're
doing it yourself it's like sometimes
you don't feel like it sometimes you
don't
do it right it's [ __ ] hot it's hot
outside and it's just kind of like
because you don't just have to move the
grass you have to like trim all the
trees and the hedges and [ __ ] like that
so we just got like the landlord said
hey we know this lawn service they
they do a bunch of other houses in the
same neighborhood yeah so
they were like we'll just add it on to
the rent yeah so they just added it on
to the rent
yeah and um so they just come like once
a week the lawn service [ __ ]
scene here in florida is a [ __ ] trip
too
it's very competitive and
during the weekdays going through
buckingham estates
you can see buckingham estates online if
you want to
it's it's good reviews and everything
they come in here the
the front gate lets them in and they'll
come in here and they try to [ __ ]
steal customers from each other too well
yeah because there's several different
lawn crews that work around this area
and they're trying to get drum up more
business yeah
and you know [ __ ] if and it's funny
because like
each person kind of is dealing with a
different long crew
well those long crews and jenny be
working she doesn't know what goes on
all the time i don't tell her
sometimes the long crew will flag you
down says you need a new wrong crew and
they're like nah
nah nah because they're already working
on the neighbors
right and it's just funny because yeah
they're just trying to get more yeah
they're they're they're they're
ethnically diverse some of them are all
south american all right some of them
are [ __ ] like
white guys and then other ones are like
all black guys and they're all trying to
step on each other's decks
to [ __ ] get on and it's just it's
just [ __ ] funny you know
it's like a mafia all these [ __ ] like
these ethnic mafias fighting over who
the [ __ ] gonna mow whose lawn
it's hilarious i wonder if the same
thing happens with like ac service
technique oh yeah i'm sure
i'm sure yeah because that's a that's
another very popular business because
honestly if you want to make like some
money in florida start like an ac
technician business or a lawn care
business because everybody
everybody wants their you know
everybody's lawns have to look pretty
everybody's got like hoas and stuff and
they
are really like sticklers about what
your [ __ ] lawn looks like
and once it's the summer time you don't
want to go out there every weekend and
do that
because you'll die you know
or it's like you know you have better
things to do i don't want to go [ __ ]
mow the lawn
and our lawn's not even that big really
i mean it's not massive
yeah now some at the back like we have
like a kind of a big backyard but
up to a certain point like um the
buckingham estates
uh their lawn crew mows it
like from several yards back from the
back fence because that's their property
i guess so they take care of all that
but we're kind of expected to trim all
the [ __ ] hedges and we're like i said
we just rent the [ __ ] yeah
tiva's saying that yeah actually owning
right now
man they wanted to sell this to me i
could buy this place i if i were to buy
it should have bought it years back
that way you know that money i would
have had a half paid off by now i mean
to be honest though
man it's time for this roof man this
we'll see okay now see that's what's
making me roop in this front i know
that like okay so the landlords are
awesome they love us
you know our rent is actually a little
bit below market value
yeah for this area and taking good care
of this house yeah because we've been
here a long time well you should we
painted the place and stuff and
uh you know the inside and then that
stuff yeah replaced there
without calling them and [ __ ] like that
however
um i'm not questioning their decision to
charge what they want to charge for this
house because that's about
market value in this area i'm i'm the
only [ __ ] who
raised his rent voluntarily i called him
says man i've been pretending you
haven't raised around no i'm gonna raise
the right i raised my own goddamn rant
well it seemed a little i mean they own
other properties but they're cool people
and um that was during the pandemic they
were getting screwed yeah
because they were losing money some
people a lot of people weren't paying
well because
a lot of people were you know lost their
jobs and they couldn't afford to [ __ ]
pay anymore so
i raised it i raised it up to a fairer
market value i was also afraid of them
selling this thing now i'm going to need
this
because they could do that but bumped it
up i will say though that if we were
going to buy a house
um for that price or you could probably
i mean you could get something
comparable and newer than this
or less yeah you can move out a little
bit further away that's all i'm saying
because this used to be damn near
country it's built up because this house
is
now is like 12 13 years old and it's in
good shape it's just but it's got some
[ __ ] that needs to be fixed like
you know some of the tile in the kitchen
is cracked and needs to be replaced
[ __ ] like that you know it's just minor
[ __ ] but it's not
it's not out like it used to be too it's
it
new stuff has sprung up around this
place and it's only a matter of time
before this
yeah it's not out in the country it's
not kind of at least we used to be on
the edge
of of korea yeah yeah
and now we're in suburbia they just
built a goddamn freeway on ramp a couple
blocks up and i just oh man yeah right
up by the gas station come out my back
gate man
there needs to be there's a damn [ __ ]
stop light out there now you know it's
bad when they're building stuff
it's time for you to [ __ ] move i
don't like that [ __ ]
for this same price that we paid for
this house here if we moved another 15
miles out into the country we would get
three times this
you would it wouldn't have to be 15
miles really yeah i mean
maybe 5-10 miles yeah we could get three
times this and that [ __ ] would be about
the same age
it'd be two stories the only problem is
you see
we're practical the air conditioning
expense the bigger the [ __ ] is
the more you're gonna pay an ac
and they're don't for one second think
you can survive
florida in a modern house without ac
forget it
no [ __ ] that the whole house will rot
and fall down and you will live a life
suffering yeah just they're not meant
for
it's no joke it's not everything it's
not obligated and
some people like oh i like hot weather i
can take it yeah but
but even if you could your house can't
take it you'll
everything will grow mold mold and
mildew every carpet will stink like a
[ __ ] rotten animal
yep uh [ __ ] will move into your house
and live with you
[Laughter]
because air conditioning kills frogs and
lizards i'll find a [ __ ] dried-up
frog underneath something
underneath the furniture every now and
then like how'd this [ __ ] get in here
they'll find their way in they come in
through the sliding glass doors and
sometimes pookie brings them in
she hides them in her mouth yeah because
she's like oh i'm gonna bring this
little guy in to play with
yeah and then she'll she'll stick it in
her cheeks yeah and they can't live
10 hours inside of ac they die for some
reason they just dry out it kills them
too cold and it's weird it's only 71
degrees but i guess it's well it's fun
for them
they like it to be all damp and it's not
and and there's no not enough moisture
for them sure
so they just dry up and die yeah but no
you can't live here without
the advent this is something that they
were talking about some guys were
talking about on youtube you had people
out in [ __ ] california trying to make
[ __ ] policy
for their all all the country about well
there shouldn't be any
air conditioning [ __ ] you live in
california all right
well some places you don't need air
conditioning the south did not really
exist until the advent of air
conditioning
before air conditioning the population
was very small here
yeah people were down here and they're
like uh no
let's let's go back it's like vietnam
this blows it's like vietnam and there's
like clouds of mosquitoes
yeah and um
when you go back in time pre-air
conditioning the late victorian houses
early 20th century houses
that i used to see in mississippi when i
was a kid
by the by modern standards they were
unlivable you couldn't live in that
they had each room had about six windows
about as wide as a [ __ ] hum of an old
human being from the 1800s in other
words about
a foot and a half two foot wide and it
was two windows that opened up like that
and it went
all the way up to the ceiling and almost
all the way up the ceiling and almost
all the way down the floor
they had like 12 foot ceilings each one
of them would like an electric fan
in the top of them and you had to keep
all those windows open to get
ventilation in the house
but they didn't really use screens i
don't think i mean at that point you
might as well just sleep outside
sleep outside and they didn't really
have screens i don't think
uh maybe they did in the early 1900s but
i'm not i don't think they did in the
1800s
when the advent of screens was well
because because they had mosquito
netting around the bed so i'm assuming
that they didn't have window screens
the houses had a porch that went
all the way around it so when you opened
the windows you walked out like a door
yeah there were glass doors really what
they were
a lot of them some of them were windows
but most of them were doors and you
walked outside on a porch a porch went
all the way around the house
like a deck and sometimes it had two
you know like a louisiana french quarter
style
houses i like what they called it a
southern colonial
french colonial i think is what they
call it but they were like
something france would have made in a
swamp and
uh most of the south was like that
those houses most of them were all gone
now but
yeah they probably like [ __ ] brought
it away yeah they rotted away there's no
way
there would have been no way to air
condition them
the ceilings were too high and there was
too much glass
uh the there was no thickness or
insulation
in them really so you couldn't insulate
them you couldn't air condition them
even if you had air conditioning you
just couldn't get it cool
miserable so you had just keep the doors
open
all the time the windows open all the
time and it would have been you'd been
living in a cloud of mosquitoes and a
whole bunch of goddamn [ __ ]
palmetto bugs roaches [ __ ] blankets
all over the place
so i don't know how they did it in the
early 1900s they had outhouses
um in the 1800s and indoor plumbing came
in in the 1900s
but before that they were just [ __ ]
in pots [ __ ] called bedpans and just
putting that [ __ ] underneath the [ __ ]
bed or putting it in the damn [ __ ]
pods
maybe they went down maybe they went
outside to the outhouse and poured that
down in here and we're not talking about
poor people these were nice houses it's
just
that's the that was the state of the
technology at the time
tila said in florida do they put screens
over the pools because of rain or
mosquitoes
mosquitoes
uh mosquitoes and to keep like leaves
and [ __ ] from falling in there yeah you
don't have to clean
bugs and to keep yeah alligators from
going in the pool
because alligator and a turtle jump
right in the pool
we went to the clubhouse pool here we
spent 20 minutes [ __ ] grabbing this
damn frog and throwing him out of the
pools
go to the because he came from the pond
and he kept jumping back in the pool
i said chlorine's gonna kill you dude
you better get out of here
you jump right back in the damn pool
he's like stopping yeah
bullfrog trying to live in a damn pool
well he was probably like hey i have
this whole pond yeah for myself
right and he was the only one in there
like i was swimming like i was doing
laps up and down and i was like
there's a little frog over there and
they don't they don't
put as much chlorine as they used to
when i was a kid when i was a kid man
there was so much chlorine in his
[ __ ] pool you couldn't open your eyes
your eyes would be [ __ ] dried out all
day
well [ __ ] see this we used to live uh a
long time ago we in uh ormond beach we
used to live
in a duplex with me and my family and uh
my dad
was the pool maintenance guy for the
neighbor for the you know complex
and they used to put so much [ __ ]
chlorine in that pool now i used to swim
a lot when i was a kid
they put so much chlorine in that pool
that my hair
turned green yeah it'll turn green tea
says she likes to look at those screened
in pools
they have screened in pools like that
here in in buckingham
we have a clubhouse one and then some
people have built their own our neighbor
has one but it's not screened in but i
think a couple
houses the clubhouse one isn't screened
in either yeah it's actually the
clubhouse one's nice though you can go
out there and you can [ __ ]
drink alcohol just keep it low i mean
you're not you can't have any glass
it's like a perfect place to pull out
your phone and do that homemade [ __ ]
porn show
that's right we're outta here
you're working it waving it's waving the
t
but no you could do it it looks like
something i have a downpour like all
most of them of modern florida does
but if you're talking about selling
we're getting back to real estate deals
and [ __ ]
it's a good time to leave san francisco
if you can get
money for your piece of property get
enough if you can sell it
oh man screened in pool you can get a
house
i don't remember how much she said
what'd she say was three hundred
thousand four hundred thousand
yeah is what she could come up with man
i think the market okay so the market
value
i think i haven't checked in a while i
think the market value for this house
which does not have its own pool
the complex has a pool this house
doesn't have a pool
this is a four bedroom three bath um i
think the market value is 325
yeah or something like that there's 425
i think
really i got 375 to 425 i think is what
it was
but t the um with the type of money
you're talking about
you could buy three three nice houses
that were built in the 90s for that
probably two maybe two
because especially if it was a little
deeper in about 10 miles in
yeah a lot of that [ __ ] you just get you
a good a lot of the houses here have
their own pools too they have their own
pools
yeah you did a place like buckingham
that that if you can find a piece of
property there is some [ __ ] for sale in
here
but there's a lot of other ones in here
that are like like well there's a lot of
other neighborhoods around here
that are like this that are actually
newer than this one you want to move
around where we are right now
that's a sanford area well this place
yes stanford heathrow
because this area is like really growing
up a lot like i said just in the past 10
years that we've lived here
they've built a [ __ ] highway on-ramp
they built a [ __ ] ton of like
restaurants
yeah and there's [ __ ] nearby like you
can like i-4
you know the main highway is like right
there it's like a mile away yeah two
miles up the road you get that four
and then ten thirteen miles down i
forget
you're you're in downtown orlando it's
[ __ ] nice
um the thing is though is that you know
a lot of like
john who owns owns ibar they're thinking
about moving out of downtown
the track the traffic has been reduced
so much
what's better is up close he wants to go
here at samford
yeah you know what i mean where the
rents are a lot cheaper and there's more
traffic
yeah it's more traffic here than there
is downtown's kind of dead right now
well because a lot of people don't live
down there they don't live down there
they're just working down there and the
age of the office building is gone
so even here these downtown areas are
going to end up being repurposed
it's just people are working from home
it's more efficient for everybody
and that [ __ ] daily commute was
tearing this [ __ ] city
up yeah they had to build
now they've made a lot of improvements
to i-4 amazingly
because we you know we don't drive on it
as much anymore obviously i'm not
commuting on it anymore
thankfully because i hate that [ __ ]
road it's full of lunatics
but um we only drive on it maybe once a
month
and when we drove on it before it's a
cigarette that's if it's a cigarette
joint no that's just it's it's an herbal
cigarette yeah and not it's not
marijuana
um uh what was i gonna say oh so it's
one of those cigarettes that doesn't
have any uh nicotine in it
or tobacco um
yeah so so we drove down it monday night
and they'd been working on it for so
long it was always a [ __ ] because you
were always like driving on i-4 and
you're like oh which side is the exit
going to be on this time or which lanes
are going to be closed it was always
like this big [ __ ] nightmare
but when you drive on it now it's like
100
better yeah they widened it they made
everything makes more sense everything
is like less dangerous they're still
working on it but it look
it's a lot better than it was yeah tia
says she can come up with 350 to 400 000
with enough left over for upgrades
so you can get something really nice
here you could probably get something
like newer than this
right and depending on what you do for a
living if you wanted to work from home
with an internet connection you can
still make good money uh
just working from home in these areas
and there's a lot of cool people here
very connected everything depends not
what
it's not just what you know it's who you
know it's a different scene very
different scene
the scene to me feel felt a lot like
san diego vista oceanside
back in the late 70s early 80s kind of
maybe late 70s
um a lot of the players from california
new york they're moving here
you know it's it's a frontier area
the only downside is the heat the
humidity but it's only part of the year
well it's most of the year it's mostly
here but it's not all the year yeah no
it's not all year and we have air
conditioning and everywhere you go is
air conditioned inside
including your car so as long as you're
not
a manual laborer you don't really have
to put up with it that much
yeah i would not want to be a roofer you
would not want to be a roofer here no
but they making good money
well justifiably right because you would
not want to be an ac
service [ __ ] because working in these
in
in a house with broken air conditioning
will [ __ ] kill you yeah [ __ ] thank
you you would not want to [ __ ]
be lawn service i mean you get a good
tan
you get hard you know
yeah i i was working in the horse
industry here i got [ __ ] pictures of
it you know [ __ ] you know
my family was involved in that too and
it's just i became
hardened to it remember how thin i was
then
yeah that went on for several years
you know training horses and [ __ ]
maintaining barns and stuff just hard
physical labor cowboy [ __ ]
yeah but it's you know i was in the
english equestrian scene
that's i grew up in that and that's like
something that's like
rock bottom that's when you you can't do
anything else you know what i mean
unless you do that even though there's a
lot of money in it but
well and especially around here i mean
it's not a massive scene around here but
a lot of these to be
much bigger a lot of people around here
do have horses they have horses and
stuff yeah
because there's a lot of like horse
farms and mansions around here that have
horses the best gig i had in that scene
was working for dr matt
yeah his mom built orlando hospital
general hospital
he's a wealthy doctor he lives just up
the road here
he's got his own barn with like um
nine stalls uh training ring
arena he's got a round pen he's got a
bunch of pastors
pastors he's got a [ __ ] real nice
southern colonial mansion
and uh his own private road that goes
out to it looks like
you're looks like disneyland in there
yeah i used to go with you out there
when you
used to work at the barn i used to go
visit the goats i used to take care of
his entire property when i was there
yeah it was his right hand man do all of
his lawns take train all of his horses
exercise his horses [ __ ]
i didn't do any shoeing you know i'm not
i i'm not [ __ ] qualified blacksmith
but
a lot of the medical stuff you know
giving horses medicine and injections
and [ __ ] did all that
and uh that was fun that was fun but uh
it gets old the heat gets to you and
then
once i finally got my [ __ ] va pension
then all of a sudden like well i'm going
out of my own doctor
all right yeah yeah i gotcha you know i
mean i remember you still did it for a
while
it didn't play for extra money that's
just man the hours
you got to wake up early and you got to
let all the horses out then you got to
ride certain horses and yeah it just
gets it gets old cleaning stalls
mucking stalls yeah because he would go
overseas so i have to take care of the
whole [ __ ]
planet yeah because no one was there no
one was there and you know he needed
some he liked to have somebody with a
military background to [ __ ] watch his
[ __ ]
make sure i was a guard dog too it
wasn't his bodyguard though but
yeah oracle said my stepbrother had his
own lawn service and died when he was
30.
skin cancer that spread to his lungs and
brain oh i don't doubt it
i don't got it either probably
because you know us caucasians have a
limited resistance to the high
uv light [ __ ] man we went to the pool
and i just i was swimming and then
i just sat out there for maybe 10
minutes and i got
[ __ ] cooked you can't really see it
yeah
i gotta go in i was trying to take some
[ __ ] selfies and [ __ ] [ __ ] it came
out funny because
i'm tan only in the front yeah it's not
red
and that was like that was like a week
ago yeah i'm about to show y'all
i don't know i shouldn't show it no no
do it do it
okay it's your picture ridiculous
zack says hey out of curiosity can you
be goth but not wear black
like can you dress in vibrant colors you
can but
i wouldn't advise it yeah
i i like black with like pops of color
i like that doing that right you can't
really use it you can't really
can't really see it but all in the
middle it's got that thread in the
middle that's all right
what can't you do i don't know you're so
vain i'm [ __ ] sexy as [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'll put on like another 10 pounds
10 pounds of muscle and lose that last
five six seven pounds
oh my god he's gonna be
give me uncontrollable jenny you're
already uncomfortable you're gonna have
to [ __ ] put me off like a restriction
uh okay i can do that okay make me stay
at home
i'll give a show what
she's not even defending it she said i'm
not defending it
yeah you get in trouble you get paid
trouble are you gonna
get something because i know you don't
like that yeah
so that'll be your punishment try to
[ __ ] me in the ass that'll be your
punishment
shit's [ __ ] ridiculous oracle said
yep he was a pale blonde his dad was
german
yeah see i'm a natural uh redhead
so you know i know that's hard to
imagine because my hair's been dyed
black for like forever
but yeah i'm a natural redhead my mom
was super super into the beach
and i grew up on daytona beach so every
weekend
she would cart all me and my siblings
let's go to the beach i'd be like god
damn it mom
so i would like i would take my walk man
in a book and i would sit under the pier
so i wouldn't get any sun yeah uh but
you know
so for a while but i like to swim so i
did kind of get like a little bit
but i always like burn zack's in there
[ __ ] yeah tom you're the man you a man
sex and they're rocking up just step
down down
slow down all right oh my goodness and
he's getting jealous because he's only
gotten so far on lockdown even my rings
are starting to feel tight
dude i told you what to do i told you
what to do you
you [ __ ] don't [ __ ] listen to me i
got dudes coming out of tom what should
i do
i'm [ __ ] getting fat man what do i
have to do
get you some [ __ ] dumbbells man all
right just buy some dumbbells and
[ __ ] start
start off with [ __ ] dumbbells reduce
your calories [ __ ] go high protein
don't worry so much about fat just eat
some meat go kind of go sim almost
semi-keto
you know for a while don't go full on
keto yeah
that's not sustainable yeah it's like
[ __ ] not [ __ ]
grease okay yeah no one wants that no
and it's not very satisfying
goat's kind of semi-keto real heavy and
lean meat a lot of
a lot of that protein shakes too you
know you know what they tell you know
you know what pretty much every
nutritionist in the world says
what the best diet is the mediterranean
diet i don't know what that is well
that's mostly like
it's you know fruits veggies fish a lot
of nuts like greek
food [ __ ] like that there's a certain
thing to be said about that but
some fruits are very [ __ ] high in
carbohydrates well yeah you gotta watch
you gotta watch one that's kind of like
your
now some people [ __ ] talk [ __ ] go
tell me what [ __ ] you talking about i'm
a vegan
look i'm i'm a vegetarian i don't want
to hear that [ __ ] okay
it has been proven he doesn't want to
hear it i don't hear that [ __ ]
because i just look at who when
i look at bodybuilders who take [ __ ]
steroids who compete professionally and
whether they got to olympia or not
and [ __ ] what they ended up looking
like and then how long they lived
i'll tell you the best diets i've seen
that are strange diets
i'm gonna call them strange diets
because they eat strange [ __ ] you know a
lot of bodybuilders they eat strange
[ __ ]
hey let's have a raw egg milkshake yeah
based on what i've seen probably the
best diet you could do is something
pescetarian
well that's mostly what mediterranean is
yeah because but very heavy in fish
yes it's measuring yeah very because
it's
very very what we call in our body build
world clean
very high in protein very low in any
kind of carbohydrates kind of low in fat
it's very concentrated protein
so in other words you're only eating 200
calories but it's
packed full of [ __ ] protein yeah
any kind of seafood is prob is better
than any other meat because it's like
there's not a lot of extraneous
people they're not huge they're not
fatty you just want to eat bambi and eat
these cows
no no no i'm looking at the [ __ ]
protein versus the calorie value
and really the best one is fish yeah
fish and shrimp
yeah because like i said there's hardly
any fat on it right the only problem
with
it is the cost if fish and shrimp were
real
cheap i'd eat that [ __ ] all day long
well some kinds of fish are cheap
if you are a [ __ ] any kind of
bodybuilder you're trying to lose weight
and you want to go to all you can eat
buffet you go to all you can eat chinese
buffet and you eat those [ __ ] cold
shrimp you just said they're just oil
trim you just
punish them for putting those [ __ ]
out
you're gonna put shrimp out on this
[ __ ] buffet
[ __ ] i'm eating all these shrimp and you
know i
you eat [ __ ] five pounds of shrimp
[ __ ] them they put it out there
it all balances out that's the thing i
can't really like i can't eat a lot in
one sitting
yeah um you know anymore
but i could probably eat my own weight
and boil shrimp
because it's just there's nothing to it
it's not greasy it's not fatty
i mean when we go to that when we used
to go to koi won
i would eat like a whole like a big pile
of boiled shrimp and
like some [ __ ] scallops like uh in
the shell or whatever
now we always got this [ __ ] and what now
we got guys in the comments but can't
you die or mercury
shut the [ __ ] up well you well you can't
but you really are you
gotta watch too goddamn much
i think mostly that's that's mostly
something that pregnant women have to
worry about yeah
don't worry about that [ __ ] i mean as
long as you're not eating like tons of
you
would never have to eat so much of that
[ __ ]
for it to shave any time off of your
life expectancy
that there's something wrong with you to
begin with you must be a [ __ ] 400
pounder or something like that i mean
like
how much do you weigh how much are you
actually eating no
no don't worry about and another thing
is is that a lot of this a lot of this
fish that people are eating today
doesn't come from the ocean where it's
picking up or mercury
that's almost like something from
another area it's mostly farm it's
farmed
so it's not really dealing with a lot of
that and i don't know if the shrimpers
farm they might be
you could probably look into that i
would imagine the the
most fish are farmed and what's funny is
that a lot of that [ __ ] like swai
grew and it lived its entire life in a
goddamn 55 gallon oil barrel
oil drum a water it's never
it's never even really been a fish i
mean and then they [ __ ] thrown
putting drugs in it to keep it [ __ ]
calm because it's never lived a life for
the fish
but some people say that's cruel but a
fish's brain is so [ __ ] small
i mean i wouldn't do that to octopus an
octopus might be as bad as intelligent
as a cat
but a fish or some people i know yeah
fish is about like a robot i would
consider a fish to be ai
it's not it doesn't have a soul if
that's what you want to look at
although i still feel anything that
struggles when you
when you hurt it um well they all do
that i know but i feel bad about it
yeah but so if you're going to kill it
just do it fish is pretty
quick a fish's brain is most fish not
all fish but
most a thing like a sway it
its brain is so [ __ ] primitive it's
just right above eel
which is about like a snake there's
nothing there they're robots
but you know what i mean when you're
dealing with things that are like cats
or whatever
even though they're if you raised a cat
inside of a barrel i imagine it would
probably be a vegetable don't even say
that
so i can't you know what's funny i i
just appealed that to a human what was
it uh [ __ ] what was his name
aristotle wasn't he talking about what
would happen if he raised a kid in a box
and he did it and wait aristotle didn't
raise the kind of bodies
who was it who is it what the hell are
you talking about yeah
did he have no i'm talking about a kid
in a [ __ ] would it be
what would it have human intelligence i
believe that i believe that which might
have been aristotle or
was it maybe socrates i don't know i
remember like the whole bf skinner in
the skinner box i remember that no
but he didn't raise a kid in a box
though but you can look it up somebody
in the comment section will probably
know more about it but i thought that he
he i know that there were as well there
were some experiments
done because people wanted to know
how much of the [ __ ] it was it was
essentially the nature nurture
argument right people want to know how
much of the [ __ ] was
uh inherent in the person's brain
and how much of it was cultural how much
of it was taught
so like okay well if we raise a kid
without talking to them would they learn
to talk
surprise they do not yeah they
essentially just
make animal noises yeah you know what i
mean
evidently uh season she just said just
in from fox russia has
has a troop built up at ukraine the
border and told the us that they'd
better back off i'm telling you
i have this all war gamed out jenny
doesn't know i stayed on top of all this
[ __ ] but i stayed right on top what
are you talking about
i understand the dynamics of power
i think it's time i think it's time for
you to put your other hat on oh that's
right
11. i have one uh sexual tyrannosaur
all right i understand the dynamics of
power i'm i'm
graduating to an actual cigarette
although this is the only one i have i
borrowed it from somebody the united
states is in no position to tell anybody
to do
things or not to do it yeah the united
states is not in a position right now to
tell anybody to do anything
russia is going to get their [ __ ] back
they're going to rebuild
a lot of that that was traditionally
part of the soviet union
they're not going to go into eastern
europe and take the satellite states
though like they don't
they're not going to try to get back
[ __ ] poland or they they don't want
that
they want the slavic nations
even though some ukrainians don't
consider themselves to be slavic but
they they want them back which imagine
if the united states broke apart
it would eventually want those states
back it's doing the same thing we would
do
now earlier somebody was saying like
united is only 200 years old it can't
break up
that's in your mind the united states is
200 years old there are other people
that could say well
actually it's about 200 years older than
that
because there were colonies here for a
lot for for
like started in the since well i mean
you can if you want to talk about the
spanish that goes back to the 1500s
st augustine's been there since 15 years
200 and something years after the
declaration of the independence
from the honky empire okay the original
[ __ ]
honky motherland the honking the hunky
emperor that's what tom's going to run
one of these days yeah
yeah i'm going to be the [ __ ] the
king of the [ __ ] hockey
i'm the emperor of the honky empire
exactly exactly
oh my god put the other hat on
i'm gonna put two hats on it they've got
the same god damn time
oh my god we might get to we might get
to lady wigs yeah
right right it's only an hour and 49
minutes in you never know what's gonna
happen
so i'm hoping for lady wigs if you look
at it if you look at it in a kind of a
crazy way
you could also say that uh
it might be closer to like 400 and
something
years old um the union is 200 years old
it
actually like officially official right
yeah i'm going to the restaurant
okay that was abrupt
[Laughter]
explain it you just did explain it
though
i don't gotta explain it but then he
explains it yeah so
yeah this is my this is my last and only
actual cigarette
i bummed this i had a couple cigarettes
left from some pack that i
got from a bar like three weeks ago
and i had some left and i smoked a
memento because i was drunk and i was
like whoa i'm gonna smoke all my [ __ ]
and then i ran out and i was bummed out
and i was really drunk and i was like
god damn it
so our friend angel still smokes and i
was kind of like
i will buy you a drink if you give me
two cigarettes so she gave me two
well she gave me one and i smoked it and
then she gave me one for the road so
good for her and i said i'll save that
i'll save that for the show when i'm
drinking when you gotta go you gotta go
right
but uh yeah well that's think here's the
thing
we were at memento right and i always i
tease him because
we are at the bar and we drink a lot
more at the bar obviously we drink a lot
more at home
but uh their drinks are like pretty
[ __ ] strong right because
they know us and they're just kind of
like okay heavy hand you know
and uh i'll i'll go to the bathroom
maybe one time
you know um but he
that night i think he went to the
bathroom i was counting because
until i got too drunk to count but i
think he went to the bathroom like six
times while i was still counting
and i hadn't even gone i hadn't even had
to pee once
i'm just like what you must have like
the world's tiniest bladder
i don't know and i'm like i have a
corset on and everything which is one of
the things i think that
that's how i i don't know because it's
just a pain in the ass like you have a
corset on you have like
fake nails on you have all this other
kind of [ __ ] and you're like oh man i'm
gonna go to the bathroom this is a big
ordeal
you know what i mean it's got like you
to reach under the corset you gotta like
be afraid that your nails are gonna
break off i have to bring nail glue with
me and all this other kind of [ __ ]
but uh yeah he'll just like kind of go
it's so easy for dudes to go to the
bathroom it's like
and they don't have to wait in line
which is another thing but eyebar is
cool because
memento when they do momento mori
they don't open they open the front
there's the front bar
and then there's the main area where the
dance floor is and there's another bar
there and then there's a little upstairs
area where there's another bar and then
there's more bathrooms up there
and there's bathrooms like right by the
front door they don't usually open that
super top
you know with the bar and the bathrooms
they don't usually open that
so there's only one ladies room
uh and it's not like stalls it's just
one bathroom and it's one bathroom for
ladies in one bathroom for men but they
will not
get all up in you because i've gone in
the men's room many times if there was
lines for the ladies
well i'm talking about eyebar oh and i'm
talking about
well you weren't here i wasn't here but
i'm gonna miss this [ __ ] wait i can't
ask what's this about
what the hell the bathroom's no because
i was saying that you
i was saying that memento like you went
to the bathroom like six times before i
had to go to the bathroom one time
yeah women train themselves
because it's a pain to go to the
bathroom well because it's a pain in the
like the size of a basketball because
it's a pain in the house and we have to
go to the bathroom because one you have
to wait in line yeah men don't want to
do it
they'll pull that [ __ ] out and [ __ ]
piss although like i said i've gone in
the men's room lots and nobody said
anything
i'm like hey nobody's in the men's room
i'm gonna use that [ __ ] it's gross
it's kind of the other way around this
little uncomfortable you don't want to
be in the ladies room
although i've seen dudes well the
bathroom's at the eye
the the men's room in the ladies room on
the at least on the ground floor
yeah because the ones upstairs are
stalls but they don't open that for
memento because it's not enough people
so they don't open that they open that
on saturday night but
it the bathroom looks essentially
exactly the same it's a one-person
bathroom
you know you go in there this toilet you
lock the door um
and they both look pretty much the same
the men's room is sometimes kind of
gross
yeah because men and they peel
everything
we're drunk they're pissing all kinds of
[ __ ] man yeah i mean the ladies room
sometimes gets gross too but not usually
yeah it's not usually so i mean you
gotta hover still
right just you know you don't want to
get any diseases but
but if you're real drunk you don't worry
about it you're just like whatever i'll
i'll deal with it
seeing what everybody's talking about
but no i was telling people yeah because
girls have to wait in line which sucks
because
chicks take forever but i know why they
take forever because i take forever
yeah and on and here's the thing too if
i'm in the bathroom
and some [ __ ] comes up and starts
rattling the doorknob i'll take longer
just to be spiteful somebody made a
comment that russia has no rights to the
slavic
nations yeah i understand what you're
saying
um but the world doesn't work that way
rights are kind of an imaginary thing
made up by
white dudes [ __ ] in the christian era
of the [ __ ] enlightenment
rights don't really exist if somebody
comes and
kills you they do what they want and
that's really how the world works
might makes right they're going to go in
there and [ __ ] [ __ ] up and take [ __ ] and
steal [ __ ] and nobody can stop them then
oh well
and that's the engine that has driven
human history from the very
very beginning and you would say well
that's wrong and they would just
kill you and when you're dead you vanish
there's not much you can do about it
after that
yeah i can't do much when i'm dead yeah
well i don't like this but you're like
in the netherlands except maybe i could
come back as a zombie
right i'm kind of hoping for that
outcome history has kind of been
handed to the people who are willing to
kill other people without compunction in
order to take their [ __ ]
in other words it's organized theft and
murder
you're not dealing with a good species
that's what prometheus was all about
you know but that's really what they're
doing
and that's actually how it is so you're
gonna get butt hurt you're gonna this
isn't fair
yeah but they're still going to cut your
head off it's unfair but they still kill
you
well the sad thing is that humans have
evolved to a point where we know that
that's bad and that's something that you
shouldn't do
yeah uh psychopaths rise to the top
because they don't care
that's what i mean but honestly i you
know it's like i know people say
it all kind of depends on how you look
at it because honestly
uh in the modern era i think we've
actually come a long way
yeah it's a lot better than it used to
be um so whenever anybody says to me
you know talking about how shitty the
world is or anything i'm like worse why
don't you take a time machine and go
back to the middle ages and then get
back to me right
and then we'll talk about shitty things
at least people at least
most people now have a concept
yeah of people's rights and hey maybe we
shouldn't do that or maybe that's bad
but
i kind of feel like they didn't have
that they didn't it was it's cyclical
um it only takes a couple generations
for ideas like that to be thought
to be forgotten and no longer become a
reality
and then then it takes a couple
generations for it to be to come back
in to a reality but the thing about it
okay so
it kind of comes and goes but like i
said humans were kind of like
and i don't mean to say i don't mean
this in a negative way
but humans are kind of like cursed in a
sense yeah
because we still have all of our all of
our animalistic instincts yeah
but we also have that that cursed
frontal lobe
yeah which is giving us a conscience and
it's giving us a sense of
yeah of empathy and things like that
with with fellow creatures not only
other humans but animals
yeah so we understand you know it's bad
to like cause
other humans or other animals and
so it's it's almost kind of like we're
in a constant war with ourselves exactly
and now here's something else
they do this [ __ ] but they rationalize
it
and they rationalize it and veil it in a
shroud of legitimacy
well you have to now that's how they do
it and they
veil it in a [ __ ] shroud of moral
legitimacy
it used to be religion in some places it
still is
they use religion to justify what they
do we are killing and enslaving these
people because they are non-believers
these are not god's people one way the
other way
is to in to enshroud it in politics
we are killing and enslaving these
people and wiping them out and taking
their [ __ ]
because they oppose us and they're wrong
that's another way you can look at it
so but in a way
what i was getting at yeah was that in a
way that sounds shitty but in a way
that's a positive development
yeah because at least now you have to
justify your [ __ ] to people
to get away with [ __ ] like that you
can't just do it anymore and everyone
will like
get away with it well no i know but at
least
you have to have that justification what
you have right now
in western civilization is two major
factions one faction is saying these
people are nazis
insurrectionists are racist we have to
[ __ ] imprison and kill them
eventually that's one way the other one
side is saying these people are
sacrificing children
they're pedos and they're commies we
gotta [ __ ] take them out of here
that we're gonna kill them too and this
has been the
same kind of thinking that's goes all
the way back
six thousand years man they've been
doing that same [ __ ] over
none of this is new well that's why this
is new
that's why i don't get like upset or
outraged about [ __ ] because
yeah i'm like reality comes in and you
have to deal with this
well and i'm taking a long view i'm just
kind of like well shit's a lot better
than it used to be
like i said decades to straighten out
what's going on right yeah it's all
right uh but you gotta look
you gotta look at it in in in in another
way
in in general individuals
are very easy to deal with it's easy to
find common ground with an individual
even if they're on the other side of
some kind of political fence
because that's a person the problem is
mass
psychologies groups groups are [ __ ]
insane
the bigger the group the more it's more
dangerous it is
um and uh it's like um
it's not herd mentality but it's kind of
more like a school of fish
well and it's because humans
uh their brains evolved
in an environment where you
knew personally 100 to 200 people yeah
and you don't get to know all these
people i mean when it gets larger than
that you can still
relate to people like if you're aware of
it but it's harder
yeah um because it's like you know you
don't know those people personally so
it's harder to
humanize them that's all it is so like
you said you know it's very easy
to say oh all those people suck
until you know a person from that
country or you know a person from that
you know you
and then it humanizes it for you so
people
need that kind of personal which
sucks but that's just the way human
brains evolved
yeah but like i said it in a way it's a
like a lot better than it used to be i i
read a really good book
a few years ago i still have it around
here someplace
uh called the better angels of our
nature stephen pinker wrote it i think
and he was making the point that you
know as shitty as stuff
is and as shitty as people perceive
things to be he's like go back to
like i said just the middle ages which
you know
going from a long view it's not really
that long ago yeah
it's like people really didn't have any
concept of animal cruelty
of human animal cruelty of individual
rights
yeah yeah um of you know oh people being
different so we should just like leave
them alone people don't really have that
concept
yeah a medieval a medieval honky man was
[ __ ]
would have been if he were to put me
nexus to a medieval hockey
it would be like putting me in i would
understand a lot of the things that he
would do
but but as soon as i saw him tie like a
stake a bear to the ground and then have
a crowd of people come and beat the damn
bear
see if you did that nowadays everyone
would flip
out yeah that's a positive development
because that's not some [ __ ] you should
be doing or like let's take all these
cats and time together and throw them in
a fire
they used to do that for fun i know and
[ __ ] um
you'd be like what the [ __ ] are you
doing why are you doing it they were
psychos
[ __ ] psychos and it's because it
wasn't a good time no because their
frontal lobes just did not develop
properly they were in a real [ __ ]
brutal
dehumanizing environment they
their sense of humor was extremely
twisted
um medieval europeans were [ __ ]
monsters
everybody was [ __ ] [ __ ] they
didn't know any better yeah
they didn't know like alien species
almost what's funny though
is that from the point of view of an
ancient greek during the golden age or
maybe like during the good parts of the
roman republic
uh the the medievals would have been
futuristic
compared to them well i got some people
in the future that's five six seven
eight hundred years away
okay you would think there would have
been like an advancement no it was like
a regression
yeah [ __ ] regret happens it happens
because the roman romans
during the good years were kind of like
a modern american
i read you can read their writing and
their thinking at least the educated
ones
real similar to a modern person of today
even
modern american modern mexican modern
brazilian yeah i mean are you about the
same
you read i i've read some aristotle and
plato
that never seemed almost modern like it
like like it happened today yeah
well even even things like uh
julius caesar's accounts of what he was
doing in in gaul
i mean he talked about well you know i
let the men [ __ ] wipe this town out
and i'll let him rape the women you know
just so they could have a little fun
then we moved on the next one we fun you
would see some [ __ ] like that you're
like what the [ __ ] this dude talking
but the rest of the writing was all like
a modern
military leader yeah and you realize
that these are all europeans
you know there were different ethnic
groups but
they weren't different races it's kind
of like a weird thing to where
you can tell that julius doesn't really
see
gauls
as fully human well that's the easiest
way to just
white people out or rape their women or
whatever yeah well
well they're beneath us they're not
civilized peoples
are savages so you can do whatever you
can do whatever you want and they're
they're savages yeah
so but you can kind of recognize well
you know what
world war ii kind of had a lot of that
in it
you know it did if you like if you watch
a lot of the propaganda films from world
war ii yeah
it was the same kind of thing yeah when
you look at world war ii process of
dehumanization well it's easier to kill
people when you don't think of them as a
person like yeah
oh the [ __ ] damn yeah exactly and you
know uh we're we're right and they're
wrong those are bad people
we can do what we want to them they're
bad and that's
that that was the thinking when you look
at what when you look at the world war
ii
hiss world war ii it's kind of
it's kind of like it from the american
perspective kind of like almost like the
high point of american history that's
when america
first came on to the goddamn world stage
as a
as a big player and we were doing the
right thing hit everyone with our
dick taken we were taking care of the
damn nazis and we were knocking the
nazis out they were evil we were
knocking these damn evil imperial
japanese out you know they were doing
bad things in china to the girls and
nanjing and [ __ ] you know [ __ ] these
japanese they're they're they're evil
you know
which they did some bad [ __ ] to the
chinese but it was they were
it was normal even in modern days 20th
century to just dehumanize the enemy
that's
really you had to do that on a
psychological level to do this
work you couldn't seem as human or you
mentally just couldn't do it
which like i said i in a way i see that
as a positive
because the fact that you have to
essentially
make your enemy seem like animals yeah
to get even soldiers that are trained
and stuff like that to just kill these
people and
cold blood or whatever um i i think
that's a positive thing because that
goes to show that humans are reluctant
yeah to do that you know and i have a
background on this be an infantry
it's very strange because you're
fighting an outside group
for some kind of evil that they have
done you were told that they did this
evil
and you're going to take it out on these
other guys they're soldiers
right and those particular guys did not
actually do an evil act
these are innocent guys from that
country that you're punishing
because that government did something
yeah they're proximately yeah
their proxies when you look at those
[ __ ] soldiers
guess what he's a dude just like you
he's just in a different suit
yeah he's got a wife and kids yeah he's
fighting for his homeland and all this
other [ __ ] yeah so you already know it's
a game but you have to dehumanize them
in order to do it
or you won't be able to do it yeah if
you can't do it then you fail as a
professional soldier and your nations
start failing because
it all comes down to the ruling class of
these nations they have
ambitions you're fulfilling the
ambitions of other people
yeah you don't really know it at the
time because you're a young soldier you
don't
see through it
as well you know what i mean you think
it's all official so it's okay
because the authorities told you you're
trusting the authorities
but you don't know who the authorities
are see i never did that well no i
thought the authorities were the
generals they weren't the authorities it
goes all the way back up into these old
families and some of these families it
wouldn't even be american families
they'd be kind of like a multinational
family so there's all kinds of hokey
[ __ ]
when you really look at it at the heart
of all these nation states it's more
like organized crime
yeah they're mafias more than anything
once you tear through all this national
symbolism
and the history and you find out who the
actual players are
behind this system and why they're
ordering this [ __ ] to be done
it's don corleone type [ __ ] but there's
corporations involved
it's complicated is it good [ __ ] no it's
not good it's bad
but it's been going on for tens of
thousands of thousands and thousands of
years that same theme
over and over again humans aren't going
to change
that's the way they are and that's just
something we have to accept
we're complicated it's complicated and
it's bad
humans are bad well i don't see i don't
think they're all bad
we're just complicated um you know
everybody has bad and good
within them but to differing degrees
obviously
if you get people like [ __ ] serial
killers obviously they're
90 90 percent bad let
no it's not correction it's to give you
a different perspective
i'm going to the bathroom though then
i'll i won't be able to do it because
it's like i'm talking to you
when you come back i'll answer that
question there's more to it than that
it has to do with the goddamn natural
selection in this society
okay let's see everybody talk about
yeah grant there's no time that's a
tribal mentality very much so
grandfather also says we're only nine
meals away from anarchy
this i can personally confirm having
lived through [ __ ] hurricane katrina
if a city population
goes uh three days without food you
start dealing with the zombie apocalypse
or the vampire apocalypse it's like some
[ __ ] out of goddamn
it was the name of that [ __ ] movie
they had old [ __ ] it's uh
had old chest and old charlton hested
[ __ ] omega man it's like something
out of omega man
all these little rules that you people
grew up with all that [ __ ] goes out the
[ __ ] window
camp guys i've heard that folks who try
to go on underground live for months or
years end up going crazy pretty quickly
well it all depends on what you consider
crazy is
um there are some people that could
handle it depends it probably depend on
who you were
there's some people that can handle
[ __ ] country life
very very well um so
now you don't have to be totally
isolated but you know living out in the
country depending on how old you are too
younger people seem to require more
interaction with others
as you get older older people don't
require human company as much
because your curiosity has kind of been
satisfied
i think hormones have something to do
with it in life experience well it
depends on the kind of person you are
because i mean somebody like me i mean
i've always you know since i was born
probably i'm
um i'm more an introverted person i do
like
interacting with people i like
interacting with you guys i like going
out every now and then talking my
friends and whatever
but if i have too much of that i get
worn out yeah
i need me time i need time just with my
own thoughts
um i i find being around other people
for too long
exhausting um and uh you know and i
think that's just
a genetic predisposition that i have
i've always been like that
okay what i was talking about jenny was
talking about things have gotten better
and people can be good yes there are
there are very there are super good
people real good people
in every civilization but advanced
civilizations like the united states and
actually you can go all the way back to
ancient egypt and ancient rome those
were also advanced
civilizations with their own legal codes
and their own government systems
and their own versions or
interpretations of what an economy is
the thing within advanced civilization
in order to gain
power and authority even in a monarchy
you must defeat enemies because there's
competition for power
there's competition for power there's
competition for status and resources
so the natural selection in an advanced
society
in the leadership class is psychopathy
people that do not have empathy for
others of their class and who are going
for personal ambitions
they must defeat their enemies within
their own system so what rises to the
top are people who are able to [ __ ]
with other people over lie cheat steal
destroy other people's income
destroy their businesses destroy their
um uh political ambitions
and when that happens when this person
is doing this
this is not just political class but
also kind of like
merchant class high merchant class which
would be like your oligarchs and stuff
or your intelligentsia when they're
doing this
the other of the others of their class
are fighting against them so it's social
warfare it's
darwinistic [ __ ] happens and what rises
to the top
is like a monster and that becomes the
[ __ ]
ruling class of the country there's not
one of them there's a bunch of them
it's a whole clique and they don't like
the rules of the country they don't like
[ __ ] morality they don't like
anything telling them what not to do
so they start buying up secret islands
all over the country and capturing your
[ __ ]
underage daughters and making them
perform for them and
they go to other [ __ ] shakes
somewhere in saudi arabia where they
have harems of [ __ ]
they do some [ __ ] that you would go to
jail for and they do it on a regular
basis
because these rules are for you they're
not these are your rules
they're not their rules they're like
they're like the gods this is another
way of looking
and they're bad but the thing about it
is that that's not a revelation that's
been going on forever if
if you have money yeah you can flat
rules you're gonna get away with [ __ ]
right that
you know normal peons like me would not
get away the difference is it's not that
i want to do anything the difference is
that in an advanced republic like the
united states there was an
illusion of a fair game
the illusion of morality the illusion of
legitimacy
one of the main attacks that they would
used against especially iraq when i
[ __ ] joined up and they [ __ ] sent
us out
at iraq the the first iraq war against
saddam hussein was how immoral
they were you know what i mean ira uh
saddam's sons uday and kusey were you
know
mostly uday was raping people's women
raping the wives of their officers in
their air force
and doing all kinds of weird [ __ ] which
he was doing he was executing women
who gave him problems he was a sexual
assault the thing about that though is
that we knew about all that even in the
90s when that fit
when that fit started yeah everyone was
like yeah it's about the money
it's about well yeah of course but
they're digging up what their ruling
class
how evil they're well yeah they're
trying to find some justification
because they don't want to tell
everybody hey it's about the money right
but i feel like most people know that
that's about the money and the power
that's what it was okay they just needed
a cover story but everybody saw
the cover story right right but what the
american people didn't know
is that our ruling class does that same
thing now that's been exposed they do
that same kind of thing
well like i said i kind of felt like
everybody already knew yeah so
no maybe you but the average person
didn't
the average person thought that the
ruling class was were good people that
oh well these are americans
you know they value human life they're
not raping our daughters or
buying slaves buying slaves it's weird
putting them on islands about it is that
in a lot of ways
i would not call myself an optimist yeah
i'm a realist
um but i understand you know not
everybody's all bad not everybody's all
good
everybody has you know a little bit of
both to
differing degrees um but i kind of feel
like i knew all that [ __ ]
like when i was a kid like i well i
don't know i've always been like a
really anti-authoritarian person
so as soon as somebody's like telling me
what to do or
they're up there like talking about you
know oh
we have to do this for you know god and
patriotism and [ __ ] i'm like what's your
angle like what are you really doing it
for yeah you know what i mean i just
i don't know i'm just like mistrustful
i've always been mistrustful of
authority ever since i was
can remember well that was because of
your upbringing and who you are
you know what i mean i i wasn't brought
up that way
you know and uh i believe
that i believe that you know good people
could actually achieve power
no good people cannot achieve power not
in this not not not in this system not
in any system
well they won't get they will but they
won't get very they won't get very far
no because a good person will not
[ __ ] over peers and
destroy their businesses to achieve
power
okay they're gonna try to get along with
everybody else
and that's how i thought it was done
that's not how it is it's not a
popularity contest
it's a con it's a contest between
vampires that's that's what it is
it's like something out of them sith
lords you watch those [ __ ] sith video
games
that's what it is it's gangsters
so that's what it is marquise bathtub
popcorn shrimp
great name by the way says damn tom
barely even talked about crustal or
death brief bummer i talked about it
[Laughter]
well the thing is is that we're going to
do a full review of that
show i thought that's what we were doing
on this one i thought no no
no no no because they sent me a blu-ray
okay if you send me a blu-ray then that
means
it it gets a show so we have to so we're
going to do it on sunday we're going to
do it on sunday it's going to get you oh
yeah see i didn't
i didn't know that yeah i thought we
were going to talk about i don't know if
you send me if you send me a dvd or a
blu-ray it's going to get a show
i'm going to have to re-title this [ __ ]
then well we can move it back to another
you can move it back to another show or
whatever but it'll get a show
so i don't want to i don't want to talk
too much about it
i wish you told me that beforehand well
you're just writing down anything no
it's good it's good we can talk about it
if you have any questions
about it you know you put them in drop
them in there we'll talk about it but uh
what's more important than [ __ ] than
death proof was the fact that
crusoe saw the phoenix lights he was the
first witness to the first official
witness to the phoenix lights
i love that that didn't come out until
later yeah and they're like oh by the
way
the first person that like reported the
phoenix lights yeah hurt wrestling with
kurt russ
in his airplane he was flying his
airplane
and he goes he's like hey uh breaker one
nine this is kurt russell
or maybe crustal maybe that's his like
cb handle i don't know
wouldn't that be funny if that was his
like if that was his [ __ ] sea battle
breaker one nine this is crosstalk yeah
con khan says
that social behavior has always uh been
there since the start of human times
it's the same [ __ ] yeah different area
exactly
going back to them when [ __ ]
khan's [ __ ] people were cutting
people's hearts out on top of their damn
aztec temples it's that same [ __ ]
power dynamic that they're going for and
i must say
khan's a proud father of [ __ ] i think
two
sons down there in mexico and he sent me
a picture of one because look how
handsome this boy is
and you did he's got he's his one of his
sons looks just like adam driver
like a real young adam driver he does
actually you want to see him look he
sent me this picture of him
wait well you should ask that's like
somebody i'm gonna show them to you oh
okay i was gonna say that somebody else
oh it's not like you know
protecting some young virginia bride i
mean a [ __ ] probably beat your
hand
yes no but i'm just saying that it's
like you you should always like ask
people's permission no i'm gonna show
you flashlights
david june says my cb handle is candy
cane
why candy cane i mean i'm not i'm not
judging i'm just asking
my dad used to be really into cb when i
was a kid i don't remember what his
handle was though
he did have one but i can't remember
what it was
he was super intense because when we
were kids we were all into like [ __ ]
smoking the bandit and all that kind of
[ __ ] so we were all into that cb
[ __ ] culture we would like uh pretend
we could break them one night daddy oh
my god he does look like adam driver
holy [ __ ]
he says i could show him okay there he
is he's a dead [ __ ] ringer
yeah look at that chip he looks just
like a driver yeah
that's a handsome guy okay 19 years old
he got his whole
life ahead of him and i told him look at
this fantastic guy
yeah i've told him it says oh he's gonna
be popular with the ladies oh i love
that [ __ ]
yeah that's nice i'm not being aware of
that's right yes
he's a handsome guy okay yeah i'm old
enough to be his mom
i'm not okay when i was his age i had
women your age [ __ ] trying to hit me
up
yeah yeah it was he's got to tell
everybody that yeah it was true
[ __ ] happened
to what keith got to say well you know
it's
it's old [ __ ] like me which we still
get like young ass dudes
yeah i still get young ass dudes hitting
on me sometimes
sometimes i'm just like dude i could be
your mom
[ __ ] up all kinds of messages
you got all kinds of masters yeah it
meant all kinds of messages yeah it's
all father's side that's kind of
fun what do you say it's all the
father-son father's side yeah he's
bullshitting because he i can see a lot
of his mother in him too
it's both y'all trying to take all the
credit for that dude come on
[Laughter]
jiggle man yeah he's got good genes
[Laughter]
i'll tell you one thing though about my
boy khan
is he's extremely creative and
intelligent guy but we have a lot of
good conversations working
on messenger about just history and
politics and culture
um but um he's
big man he's a big mexican dude he's
like close to six feet tall
that's like elite size i think he's six
one
so when you talk about all this temple
sacrifice and [ __ ] he was the one at the
top of the temple [ __ ] telling him to
do it see
he wasn't
yeah that's why they got smaller because
they were trying to sacrifice the
biggest one
trying to he's six yeah because he's six
when he says it's true
that's true that's he he's like uh
uh in mexico he's like one of those
engineers
yeah yeah i can't relate i'm like a
short [ __ ]
yeah yeah well i'm short too
true yeah one of the weirdest
experiences for me because i'm five foot
three maybe if i'm lucky i'm gonna go
the restroom hold on
a second i might have to change my hat
really oh my god we're getting closer to
wig territory
you're gonna have to get me a new drink
too in a second um
one of the weirdest experiences for me
because like i said i'm five two five
three maybe
and uh before i was before i was going
out with him
i was dating a guy well my ex-husband
was actually six foot one six foot two
something like that
so a lot of people made fun because they
were like oh look he's like a foot
taller
and then before i started going out with
him i was dating a guy that was six foot
five
and he could literally pick me up and
carry me around like a backpack
like that's how much bigger he was than
me and it was just like the weirdest
[ __ ] experience ever i'm like i'm
used to being
smallish you know what i mean like i'm
not a
little waif or anything obviously but
i'm just i'm a short [ __ ] so
it's just it's really funny to me like
it's just this big dude and i was i was
a lot thinner than i will say that
um but yeah so he could just like pick
me up and carry him around like on his
back and now and i was like half his
size
and it was just it was kind of neat but
it was kind of weird at the same time
um i saw something oh tammy said my
mom's cb handle was ladyfingers
oh my god that's excellent
my cb handle was blonde bombshell i gave
you that name and i'm a guy don't ask
oh but you know i'm gonna ask though
like
see i wish i could remember what my
dad's cb handle was because i remember i
thought it was funny but i can't
remember what it is
i remember me and my brother me and my
brother eric
who is four years younger than me when
we were kids
my dad was really into seabees and uh
cause you know like i said smoking the
bandit everybody was into that [ __ ] back
then
and i feel like we we used to play cb
all the time and he had a cb radio and
he had a handle and i wish i could
remember what it was
[ __ ] man i have to ask him i've talked
to my dad in a while but i have to
ask him where should she be handled back
in the [ __ ] 1980s
because i can't [ __ ] freak i can't
remember did the milfs
young love young tom every here's the
thing everybody loved
tom when tom was uh
a teenager he looked like
um he looked kind of like
rick springfield a little bit he had
like that same kind of
feathered hair it wasn't a mullet well
because that was kind of like the
the cool hairstyle in the 80s like i
said it wasn't exactly a mullet but it
was kind of like feathered sort of
and he had like he always had that dark
hair because his hair is like really
dark
so he had that kind of thing going on
and um
so yeah you know i don't know i wasn't
there i didn't meet him until he was
you know in his 40s probably but um
from what he tells me and from what i've
heard of people that knew him back then
um yeah he was he was very popular with
the ladies
you were very you were the drinker yeah
i was telling him how you're very
popular with the ladies when you were
younger when i was younger
because you looked kind of like rick
springfield
[Laughter]
at least your hair did not your face so
much but his hair kind of looked like
brick springfield's hair back then
you know like jessie's girl
oh my god yeah he did he kind of look he
had hair like that
but his face didn't look like that i he
showed me pictures of him from back then
and um yeah he was a cutie pie back then
um i even made like a joke
of i took a picture of him well my
favorite picture of him like as a
teenager i think he was 17.
and i took a picture of it and i
photoshopped him onto
the cover of like uh teen beat or bop or
one of those [ __ ] teen magazines from
the 80s
like i think i rubbed out see thomas
house they want to see that yeah and i
put
i don't even know what happened to it
but i did it was really good and like we
posted it
and i think a couple of people thought
it was real yeah they thought which
which i thought i was like well that is
a testament to my photoshop skills
because a lot of people did think it was
real i also photoshopped you into a
picture with evel knievel
yeah yeah i picture i photoshopped you
into a picture with the go-go's
which that was my favorite one i looked
like merle from walking dead
well now he does yeah not back then
though no no we all had mullets in 87.
yeah a lot of a lot of people did
and it's weird because the mullet i feel
like i don't know i need to look into
like a cultural history of the mullet
has anybody wrote a book on that
probably
but i feel like there hasn't been that's
the picture i'm talking about look ccc
how you were like what 17 yeah something
like that
or seven sixteen or seventeen that was
the picture i used
yeah yeah i put him on the [ __ ]
it wasn't quite as feathery as i
remember another that's another picture
oh my god we're good it says the trip
down memory lane
no one's seen any pictures of me back
then yeah tom looks like merle from the
walking
like i said now he does but yeah a few
years later though i look like that
yeah okay so you got your haircut yeah
yeah the mullet are sort of like
that haircut i feel like in the 80s i
associated that more with like new wave
right yeah yeah it was more of a new
wave thing that was like the cool people
thing and then it only became
rednecky lately after yeah like
emulating what we were doing well after
that became like
you know that was kind of like over yeah
and then kind of like
rednecks that were stuck in the 80s yeah
they were like kept that hairstyle into
the 90s they were like 10
15 years behind yeah i think that's what
it was
because honestly you know you'd see in
the early 80s you'd see dudes like
[ __ ] howard jones or like
uh lamar from kashugugu or whatever and
they had
you know even like the duranderan dudes
had something that
approximated a mullet um and
no one called in a mullet back then
everybody said oh
yeah it was like a cool like new wave it
was european
punk rock looking hairstyle everyone
thought you were like yeah everyone
thought you were in a punk or a new
waiver
it was like something you see on [ __ ]
catch-a-goo sabrina says young tom was
hot
yeah i was
oh not anymore
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey you [ __ ] you say [ __ ] to me like
that all the time no it looks like
you used to be cool you used to be cute
you oh yeah
really yeah i didn't say you you used to
be yeah right yeah okay
so you know whatever just getting
something back to you everybody gets old
it's not true everybody gets old that's
what happens
hockey players out of yeah and actually
on mst they call it hockey hair
hockey they did a whole uh they well i
think it was
uh [ __ ] man what was that canadian movie
they did with [ __ ] roused hour
i can't remember the name of the movie
but yeah he had like a super
uh egregious mullet and they did a whole
sketch about
hockey hair and how it was like a
disease and they had to treat it it was
like [ __ ] funny i'm trying to find
where
the photos are okay huh yeah
you know you can't if i have the picture
you're talking about
i thought that was the i thought that
was the one that i know i have several
of them from that period
i mean you gave me like a [ __ ] ton of
photos from back from when you were like
a little kid
when you were a teenager um or in your
20s and i just like put them in
okay whatever pictures i put you in with
david bowie i put you with like freddie
mercury
um i put you in with andrew eldritch
i'm trying to think of like all that i
did like a whole series of them and we
posted them all on facebook and they
were super funny
and i think some people did actually
believe they were real because like i
said i tried to do
them as realistic as possible the
go-go's one i think was my master
achievement because
i found the perfect picture
of the go-go's because it was all of
them and brenda carlisle
belinda carlisle rather belinda carlisle
was at the end of the picture and her
arm was
out like that but no one was there
uh but the picture like extended and i
was like oh my god
that was like made for that so i took
the picture and i put tom in there and
he looked like he was looking over at
like all the members of the go goes and
they were like
looking at them like hey here's a little
time
that's what she's talking about yeah you
know see oh my god it was like
because her arm was just like out like
that that was back when i was on tour to
go
most
[Laughter]
that was my favorite one well i think
that one was my favorite or the one with
you with evil knives was my favorite
because that was when you were little
and you had your little stp jumpsuit on
and i put you in a picture with uh with
evil knives
before he did his uh that
big stuff or whatever what about that
time what about the time i jumped up on
stage and jammed up with [ __ ] ready
mercury
[Laughter]
yeah i had such a good time doing that
or that time i jumped up on stage and me
and bowie [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i wish you can you find that one that i
did with the with the teen magazine
cover
yeah like i said i think i shopped uh
see thomas howell out of
off the cover look at this cat she's
tearing up the back of the chair
what are you doing baby girl god what
are you doing go
what's yeah taylor says these picks are
hilarious yeah
i had all kinds of [ __ ] i know i i i
had a good time doing those
he gave me like a whole pile of pictures
from like back in the day
and i just like put him he gave me some
suggestions but then i just kind of went
and
she did my and she did my own thing
trying to find
i was just trying to amuse myself that
shit's just all kind of scary okay here
we go
tiger beat that's what it was tiger b
this is the time they featured me on the
cover tiger beat
see yeah 12 sexy color pinups yeah
i put that in there yeah
[Laughter]
maybe that's my favorite one
[Laughter]
you came up with that one on your own i
did yeah i just looked and i started
laughing
i'm trying to see if there's any more of
them the me and evel knievel
yeah where's that one a lot of this is
me when you were little in the club in
the club look at the jaboos
seriously there's a lot of them i feel
like half of his pictures are that
me looking at her boobs laughing going
yeah yeah boobs
i did stupid [ __ ] back in the day what
are you talking about you still do
stupid [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah look at young jenny [ __ ]
belly shirt on and [ __ ] [ __ ] boobs
popping out
oh and look there's shauna and zombie
yeah
that was uh how many years ago was that
uh probably four five six years ago five
or six years ago
yeah maybe longer now
really a lot of this [ __ ] i look back at
it and it wasn't
it feels like it was a million years ago
i look a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton younger
it was really only like five or six
years ago
that was like see look at that's
probably about seven eight years
seven years maybe it doesn't tell you no
yeah it might have been seven or eight
years ago yeah
seven or eight years ago i think that
one certain point man in a [ __ ] year
takes a lot off of you well the one with
the zom baby that was at
um mitter knocked yeah
uh and how long ago was that like mitter
knocked
holy [ __ ] the um yeah i don't think we
mentioned this on the show but
a dude we knew dj ld
who used to dj mitter knocked here in
orlando he died in a car accident yeah
not too long ago i'm always talking
about indian princess
and [ __ ] tori this is tori that she she
is a real
indian princess they're gonna talk about
these indian princes and [ __ ]
but her dad is like terry's rad yeah her
dad
and she's like a punk rock indian
princess her dad is in um
like indian affairs in washington dc
that's what she does
she's cool as [ __ ] she had a lot of fun
with her yeah i love her i'm in theater
in a while but yeah
i think her hair was bright blue last
time but she had like the whole rainbow
thing going for a while and it was like
really cool looking
she always had like that big teased hair
but it was always like it was either
rainbow she had green for a while she
had blue for a while
manners got so many photos i can't find
she was a uh she's a macaw
indian they're from like a washington
state they're like whale hunting type
indians
um similar to like inuit
which are some people call eskimos but
they're like they're like the inuit
inuit
yeah yeah she's right as hell yeah
bright blue eyes and everything
i think the last time we saw her was at
that comic book thing that we did
because he was in that movie right
yeah it was yeah all right
she wants to come out but there's like
reasons why she won't come out
says she gotta go on a diet first man
don't say that no it wasn't she
you just did i told her i said don't
worry about don't worry about it
[ __ ] you know what i mean [ __ ]
just come on out
to come out check them out event
especially some people you know what i
mean they [ __ ]
have uh standards and [ __ ] they're like
all right
i guess wait i don't want to come out is
it i
you know what i get that though yeah and
it's like [ __ ] what are you worried
about i saw i
saw how she looks i think it was like
this you're worried about nothing come
on out
yeah i mean i mean nine times out of ten
they are worrying about nothing
yeah she's worried about nothing but i
but i get that feeling it's like
especially for girls because
you're gonna get judged on what you look
like more than a dude would
um so you know yeah if you gained a
pound or two and then like suddenly your
[ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't fit right and then
you're just like okay well [ __ ] this i'm
not going anywhere because i look like a
i look like shamu like i get that you
don't look like shamu
but you feel like you do i get it
grammars
gram there so i went to high school with
said jocks had mullets football players
had
bo bono wannabes had them everybody had
them back then yeah they all had we all
had them see i don't really we didn't
know it was a thing we just thought that
was what you're supposed to look
well that was the way everyone's kind of
hair look although i will say
i mean i grew up in uh central florida
so i grew up in daytona beach which was
kind of rednecky
yeah so really the only people that had
multi hairdos in the 80s
were like punk rockers and new wave
people jocks had
short hair if you had multi-looking hair
everyone said that you were gay yeah um
and would beat you up
you're right um so you know what i mean
people are nursing they were still
very like you know we have to have like
short people are never saying how i
could have been in the movies and all
that and
another guy another guy said that look
like james dean
that was actually that was uh
that was that was uh that was constant
look like james dean yeah i actually
called it
because when i was a kid people that
used to say that all the time they look
like james d
but nowadays people don't even know who
james dean is a lot of these people so
they can't they don't know what it looks
like i mean
younger people don't so you called it i
actually probably looked
because t was saying it looks like kevin
bacon no it's not how i looked in person
a person was closer to james dean i
could kind of see the kevin bacon thing
but um everybody used to
say that i reminded him of james dean
all the time when i was in high school
grandparents can [ __ ] back that up
i would always get rolls rolls and plays
and [ __ ]
because they were james d type
characters which i [ __ ] hated that
[ __ ] but that was just
that's the way it was let's talk about
your uh you all you're the musicals you
know i don't want to talk about that you
don't want to talk about that no i'll
talk about that with a bunch of them but
i don't talk about it i was in some in
brazil too
they did commercials in brazil i didn't
see i didn't know that
yeah ice cream commercials it's a
company called kibo
let me or how good kimono ice cream i
did like four of them
i don't think you ever told me that ever
yeah i did like for them
like tv commercials yeah tv holy [ __ ] i
didn't know that i didn't get paid much
for it
did like all four of them in one day got
about a thousand bucks for it
somebody find those on youtube
[Laughter]
somebody must have saved those i don't
know
[Laughter]
i feel like people saved everything
because [ __ ] man
should i [ __ ] that i had forgotten from
like the 70s and 80s you look on youtube
and it's like there it is
brazilian television commercials turned
over rapidly even faster than american
television commercials they made them
cheap
and they were kind of like very local
productions most of them are like
only sao paulo and sao paulo and [ __ ]
rio de janeiro you know and they might
have been regional
and i think they were only on tv for
about a month or so
that was it interesting yeah me running
up in a school [ __ ] giving another
girl [ __ ]
giving this girl uh who she was
brazilian
i was giving her an ice cream bar and it
was just it was just a couple shots it
was only like three shots
that was it me running and then hurt
kidding and then her smiling that was it
there wasn't really nothing because it
was just a few seconds long the whole
thing
there was voiceover it didn't matter
yeah
yeah i forgot all about it kind of till
now
because like i said yeah i don't think
you ever told me that i knew you were
like in stage musicals and stuff but i
didn't know you'd been liking it it's
not that at my school because
it was a nice school it was a foreign
but they brought the girl
in from the general population she was a
model
she was hot but probably a hooker
probably probably yeah okay
i think the only thing i was in i was in
showboat when i was a kid
like a kind of a bit part yeah i was an
annie
as a kind of a bit part um i was
i was in the chorus so we did chorus
[ __ ]
i wasn't in a lot of the acting [ __ ] you
know what i mean yeah
i always i always kind of thought about
it and then i was like
i don't know i don't like that much
attention on me man
yeah kind of wig it kind of wigs me out
i didn't mind like being in a small part
i think i was in i got in showboat
because
it was something to do with my uncle
who owned he owned the kfc franchise i
think it was in tampa or st
pete or something and then he had like a
little dinner theater like next to it
so it was like you know and they were
doing like a big production of it there
and i got it in there didn't see it i
look like michael rooker
like i said prob well maybe now you're
not that grizzled
michael brooke we saw if you go back and
you go look at [ __ ] michael when he
was young that was a good-looking dude
he was very good-looking yeah well it
got type cast he was
also from mississippi and that's
probably why some people are saying that
because if you put a side by side we
don't look alike
but you're saying that because of the
mannerisms most likely the mannerisms
and the voice
because we both kind of have mississippi
dialect yeah you don't look like him in
the face yeah no
similar mannerisms and stuff but that's
almost regional
so that kind of person i think you know
what i think
is that's cool about michael rooker is
that he comes across
as real it's not even what he looks like
it's he just comes across
as very genuine and he comes across as
really like charismatic yeah well he has
to be very friendly
in uh when he's a guest on any kind of
shows or any kind of interviews
he has to to to differentiate to show
the [ __ ] general public that he is
not those villains that he's [ __ ]
polite
because he gets typecast yeah well and i
feel like that happens a lot
with actors that
you know that play you know obviously he
got his start well i don't know he
didn't get start but it it's big
breakout role was you know
playing henry lee lucas henry so he
played a serial killer
and then you know he played merle on
walking dead and [ __ ] like that
so i do kind of feel like i don't know
if it's just
actors that get type cast as playing
villains are just nice dudes and they
enjoy playing villains
and they get all their evil [ __ ] out
when they're playing the villains yeah
or like you said if they feel like
because they play villains they
feel like they have to be extra nice
they have to be extra nice
to like talk about everybody know that
that's not really me
yeah i'm not really a terrible person
like that
although i tell you what
i liked the first like four or five
seasons of the walking dead
yeah we know it was an excellent
survival horror
series it got very hokey
as it went on you cannot hide behind
sheet metal
you know i mean when it comes to assault
rifles they'll go through a [ __ ] inch
of steel at 100 yards
they're especially any kind of
armor-piercing type of [ __ ] tongues
and core around or anything you know
they go through [ __ ] you can't hide when
i started seeing that [ __ ] i said i
gotta check out
like th this is just i i cannot suspend
my disbelief anymore
although like i said i feel like they do
that in a lot of movies too yeah and
they shouldn't
like they shoot through [ __ ] that you
like
the first few seasons of the walking
dead what made it good is that it
kind of was something you could kind of
learn from it was kind of realistic
you're like yeah that's probably how
that would go in that situation
you know um but i will say this
the two dixons in the story
even though they're very much
stereotypes were very believable that's
the way
a lot of real hardcore mississippi
alabama well yeah
you could see why so many people were
related to this character
and why daryl is still [ __ ] on there
as far as yeah that's
that's basically what you're talking
about and uh
yeah they had guys like merle there
weren't a lot of them but they had guys
like that
and uh you know they were not they would
not be politically they would not be
socially acceptable you know what i mean
in places like [ __ ] california or or
new york
you know or anywhere really they're
hardly socially acceptable even in
mississippi for some of the [ __ ] that
they did but they're there
and they're kind of like that but what's
weird about them is that they can still
be kind of [ __ ]
interesting you know i mean they're
they're still interesting guys
that's that's what they're like well and
i think that's all anybody wants i don't
think anybody cares even when they're
watching a tv show
they don't care about oh this is a good
person or this is a bad person
is this an interesting one yeah and that
was what was great about merle mauro was
a mixed bag
okay yeah he had a lot of bad in him but
in the end he
he had good in him too um
he was a a complicated character
you could say he was a villain but in
the end he ended up sacrificing himself
for michonne didn't he
and his brother yeah well yeah the thing
is well
that's what i liked about his character
is that even though in a lot of ways
yeah he was kind of a dick
but there was some good in him too and
that's what i think people like about
daryl
yeah is that he's a conflicted character
like he does some [ __ ] that maybe people
wouldn't like
but he's still a good person yeah you
can tell he's a good person yeah like he
cares about people
daryl knew he didn't have to uh merle
knew
that in the long run he had no future in
the situation that he was in
so he went out [ __ ] save and try to
save good people he kind of knew he was
a bad guy but in a way atoned for it
yeah i really like that and like i said
i think that's a good right and a tone
for it are you a bad person are you
after that are you a bad person well
obviously you know
because then you'll end up like no he
was because if you know if you
if you've acted like a [ __ ] in the
past when you realize that
and you try to rectify it yeah then
you know obviously no you're not a bad
person yeah a bad person would just keep
on doing what they were doing and not
give a [ __ ] with anybody
he wasn't selfish in the end right and
in the end
he was uh a good dude he
he he went out with honor he saved other
people
uh he turned his back on his ways that
that's
yeah which like without compromising his
core characteristic which was strength
he was about strength and he was about
fury but he redirected it
you know what i mean redirected it into
something that was good
which was to save others that was the
only choice he had at the time he did
that
really good writing really good writing
yeah that's what i mean and i think
that's why people still remember that
character fondly
yeah because you can be like a bad guy
you can do shitty things but if you
realize that you're a shitty person
and you try to atone for it you do
something good later i think people will
respond to that more than they'll
respond to somebody that is
unrealistically good or unrealistically
bad because nobody is like that
nobody is all good or all bad there's no
perfection
exactly everyone is kind of a mixture
like i said and everybody i think most
people
know uh at least most people with
self-awareness know that you know you
try to be a good person
but obviously everybody has you know bad
[ __ ] that they do
they've done [ __ ] they've ashamed of
every you know everybody has yeah
so i think that people can really relate
to
characters like that yeah because it's
like hey they're like me
yeah you know what i mean they did
shitty things but they kind of made it
up
for it in the end david june said he
played riff-raff and community theater
performance on rocky horror yeah we know
the real refraction oh my goodness yeah
yeah that's good
i used to go to rocky horror every
weekend for many years
yeah session and i knew i knew the girl
that played magenta she went to high
school with me
you know david june came out he said you
know that character a lot like vader
like dropped him yeah he is he was
yeah he was kind of like darth vader he
was the southern darth vader even though
darth vader was souther
[Laughter]
james earl jones was from mississippi
yeah he was an army ranger that's right
yeah so it's kind of the same it all
kind of comes back like i said i think
that's kind of why a lot of people
relate to daryl as well because it's
like he has like a lot of the same
characteristics as mural
but he's more conflicted
about [ __ ] he has to do um he's
stoic but you can tell that there's a
lot going on
even though he doesn't talk much are you
talking about daryl yeah yeah
the difference with daryl is that is
that daryl was not the
was not really the aggressor he wasn't
an aggressive kind of guy trying to
impose on others he was a more uh
introverted well and he and it was
interesting
with him and when merle was still alive
because
merle was the reason that he was like
that yeah because merle was his big
brother and used to like beat up on him
and [ __ ] with him and [ __ ]
and that's kind of what made him turn
out like that and there was
well it was also the family background
that was going on and
the thing is because they all got like
molested right
they didn't they didn't really say that
well that was implied they were beaten
at least
yeah i think they were just beaten yeah
um
the but what was what was
kind of a waste was was when
we're talking we're talking about daryl
daryl's
main episode where he came into a real
character was the chupacabra
episode where he remember he survived on
his own
yeah and he's hallucinating that he was
seeing
in uh merle yeah i remember that yeah
and that was really that was the episode
where i was like yeah i like this
character a lot
the thing is though is that i am
convinced that
thank you david he says where's all the
super chats at tonight yeah we're on a
[ __ ] super chat
the uh that's all right i was yeah we're
just doing our job man we're just
working
but um i was kind of
i was i was expecting them to kind of
expound on the [ __ ] chupacabra angle
because i was convinced that he did see
a chupacabra but he didn't know what he
didn't know what it was
like done a whole little spin up [ __ ]
with that later on
they're actually being a chupacabra
there was yeah
i kind of thought that maybe what the
chupacabra was going to be
was going to be kind of like a zombified
test monkey
see that's what yes we were talking
about that we were talking about well
they wouldn't have brought it up
right we thought it was going to be like
a
a zombified dog or a zombified animal or
something i would think it would be
i think it would be an escaped test
model that would have been a good thing
for them to write in
yeah that was that was patient zero that
was patient
one that's where the zombie outbreak
came from
was that infected yeah see that's what
we were thinking daryl saw it
and that's how they should have done
that but they they they missed
that opportunity yeah it's almost kind
of like they brought up the chupacabra
thing and then they didn't really do
anything with it
because he goes he goes i thought that
was leading up to something bigger
because maybe they had something to do
with them on their mushrooms he was
eating because i know what i saw
as soon as he said i know what i thought
i said he he did see it
because it mississippi that's how that
[ __ ] comes i know what i thought
so it was true if you say it in a
certain way you know it's true
it's like yeah i drank a whole bottle of
jim beam that day but i know what i said
[Laughter]
but i'm just saying that the fact that
they and honestly wasn't that episode
called chupacabra called chupacabra i
kind of it's the best
they made a big deal out of it that i
feel like i thought it was going to like
relate to something later on like
i thought it was going to be like
patience they were going to find out
later on like i said
that was what had caused the zombie
outbreak is like some zombified dog
like escape from a lab or something
which would have that would have tied in
really nicely but i guess
they never did that you can only see one
if you could only see one
walking dead episode it's that one
chupacabra i think it's season two isn't
it that one or the one where carol like
shoots the kid
there were better ones than that though
i know but i really like that
yeah anytime anybody's willing to like
[ __ ] up a kid
yeah i'm on board for that what's that
you know what i know that sounds weird
but
yeah i just feel like they don't really
have the balls to do that a lot of times
i'm just saying um you know
somebody said like camp guy said it's
going to be mid 30s tonight here and
somebody's like covering up their tomato
plants holy crap
where the [ __ ] do you guys live it's
warm here i mean it's been raining for
like the last three days
should i let books out let me go that
poker wait is she is she complaining
she was complaining earlier if she's not
complaining now don't let her out
it's dark okay and get something it's
starting to get dark where yeah
come on i mean it's only eight
yeah look at the flowers i mean
i don't know i feel like there's a lot i
gotta catch up on i've been talking to
like michael from a starry night who is
still watching it
he's like like he's like [ __ ] you have
to like watch the new one
and i just haven't gotten around to it
yet i don't know i will but
i don't know i'm i'm not you know i
i'm not like that he's like oh it got so
much like a soap opera
i don't mind that um but
i don't know i kind of feel like a lot
of the characters i liked are gone now
and it's like the new ones they
introduced are okay
but it's like not the same
i don't know maybe i just got jaded on
the [ __ ] because honestly i remember
i remember watching the [ __ ] episode
and i'm sorry this is a spoiler if you
guys haven't like watched the whole time
but that episode where [ __ ] negan
busts in [ __ ] glenn's head with the
baseball bat
and his eyeball pops out and she'll like
that i was like flipping
out i was flipping out and then i feel
like a season or two after that
i was just kind of like man i really
wanted to get into it and i just
couldn't
because i i kind of felt like all the
characters like rick left
and then he didn't even die he just kind
of like soft
died i guess and after that happened
like i still love uh daryl i love carol
i would honestly i would like to do
because i think somebody mentioned
earlier that they were gonna do a
spin-off show
i would watch that because honestly
those two i like maggie too
but most of my favorite characters are
gone
so i don't know they introduced a lot of
new characters that are cool but it's
like you don't really get to spend a lot
of time with them because there are so
many now
um we watched fear the walking dead for
like two seasons
and i was like i couldn't really get
into it and then i was like oh
super ballsy they killed off like the
main character which i thought was
like really cool but
i don't know by that time i had kind of
lost interest
so i don't know and i'm not one of those
people that's just kind of like oh i
lose interest immediately because i
don't
we stopped come on
come on come on come on
is it back okay that was my
um hopefully you guys are still there
okay
all right yeah that was my uh that was
my streaming program
said it disconnected momentarily but
then it said it reconnected
so hopefully i'm looking he has his
tablet over here
with the stream on it okay it works
but yeah i don't know
like i said i feel like they should and
honestly i watched like you know the
show that daryl did was like where he
was just doing like motorcycle tours
like around the country i watched all of
those
because that dude like norman reedus
seems like a lovely person
he just seems like a lovely person in
real life he just goes around and he's
like
goes to these [ __ ] roadside places
on his motorcycle he went to all these
different doors and then didn't go out
that's okay well she doesn't want to go
don't make her go she wants to look
outside i mean close the door a little
bit because
i don't know if right how that's going
to go
i mean don't close it all the way
because she might want to come in but
later
she's got me jumping all over his foot
okay well no i'm just telling you
there's no work back way back
yeah is it still going i was still going
well because my
uh my obs crashed it did but then it
came it disconnected
here yeah they're saying it looks like
it's slow
but these is slow on his hand looks
normal here on mine
yeah it kind of we lost uh we lost my um
my uh obs for a little bit that's that's
some herbal [ __ ] huh yeah it does not
smell like a cigarette
yeah it's herbal it's no it's no
nicotine no tobacco
i don't know what the [ __ ] in there
wait here okay if there's no nicotine
let me get a drag
because it can't get hooked on that
really yeah that's not bad yeah that's
what i told you
i got those a long time ago generally
care about the damage it does to your
lungs i don't want to be addicted to it
yeah yeah there's no there's no nicotine
in that
i don't even know what's in there but
it's not a nicotine that's not
or tobacco yeah i just got those off
[ __ ] amazing
psychological because those are like
legal to sell you you know what i mean
so you can get them easy
yeah tammy said norman's the reason i
started watching walking dead liked him
from boondock saints yeah he was great
in boondock saints
he was in um uh what do you call it
masters of horror the john carpenter won
cigarette burns he was in that as well
yeah uh
which he playing completely different
character
but yeah it's like honestly
he's him and carol are kind of the best
characters on there
you know nowadays i haven't seen
i think the last season i missed maybe
two seasons
and i there's a new spin-off now too
not fear the walking dead it's uh [ __ ]
man what's the call
i think it's like whole new characters i
don't trust walking dead i've heard that
was good but i've heard it was good but
i haven't seen it yet so i'm not making
a joke yeah they're kind of
i don't know fear the walking dead was
good for a while and i'm going where's
this [ __ ] going you know what i mean
although like i said i will give fear
the walking dead
uh props for having the balls to kill
their main characters off
well cause nobody liked them in you know
the second season or whatever it was
but you know well they didn't do
anything with them
that was a problem they're right yeah
but by the time that happened i was just
kind of like eh
yeah they did well the thing about it
i think let me let me get one of those
okay
i want to pull one i can smoke that as
long as there's no nicotine
in it yeah it's not see it so i'm sorry
no nicotine
no okay tobacco is do we have an ashtray
it's over there do you want that right
over here where i can put it
all right oh we're going we're going
full yeah he's going into like [ __ ]
yeah it's not a long time long as long
as i i just smoked one
there you go without having a craving
not that well i didn't know if you were
doing it or if i were doing it
see not bad right you didn't like
yeah you get it they they're kind of
hard to light that's the only thing
because it's not you know it's not too
bad
they're kind of like grass it's kind of
like a
it's hard like a cigar yeah smokes like
a cigarette but it doesn't have the same
hit
as a cigarette yeah yeah it's kind of
mild there's absolutely no nicotine
rush yeah well it's just kind of like
it's like it's not it's like a vape
yeah it's like a vape it's very very
mild so you can feel like you're doing
it that's why i ordered them to see what
they were like yeah it's not bad
yeah very mild
that's doable that's good for a club
yeah well like i said there you can get
them on amazon
they're like i said it's not nicotine so
they're illegal to sell them okay
don't worry about the 18 plus thing yeah
because that's where i got them before
um i think the thing that they made a
mistake with the fear of the walking
dead is that
they wanted to go back and start at the
beginning of the of the
zombie outbreak again um
but with different people in a different
area jacob
which like i said that could work but we
already saw that
because we already saw that on the
walking dead we saw
the beginning of the outbreak we saw the
[ __ ] so i kind of feel like yeah that's
kind of what would have happened
anywhere
um you know what i mean so it's not
quite as interesting
that's all i'm saying because it's just
[ __ ] you've already seen
tila said she initially thought it was a
cigar
you were smoking and then she thought it
was joint too no it's a little bitty
herbal thing
it's got a filter on it yeah it's
burning fast though i'm halfway through
it already
there yeah they're herbal cigarettes
like i said i got them a long time ago
off of amazon because you can sell them
legally because they don't have
uh tobacco or nicotine in them yeah and
uh
they're good they're smokable though
yeah if you guys are right if any of you
smokers have ever had like a merit
light which is like smoking [ __ ] air
it's like that
but me being an ex-smoker
it's kind of nice to have that ritual
yeah that's right that's why i got him
but it's kind of like
because if you ever want that like i
said if i'm having a drink or if i'm
having like a cup of coffee and i want
like a cigarette with it
right you can have that you can have a
non-addictive cigarette at least it's
not
and it still feels like a cigarette i
feel like a cigarette but it's not like
a vape
you know what i mean i can't even do
vapes anymore because it like makes me
cough
i did kind of lose that ability to deal
with [ __ ] smoke but yeah
it's not bad though it's real [ __ ]
mild yeah i thought
i could order a pack of these i'll smoke
these deer in a club yeah and they're
like
probably wouldn't have i've had this for
like uh probably a year
so you don't you don't have it oh so
they may not be totally fresh
yeah so you don't have a uh you don't
have that urge to [ __ ] smoke one
constantly then
no okay like i said it's just it's every
now and then if i'm out
and i drink or every now and then like
if i'm working and i'm stressed out
i have a cup of coffee or something like
that i'm like man i wish i had a
cigarette right now you can grab one of
those but
like i said i've had this pack for
a year in fact i'd had them so long that
i forgot where they were
yeah it was time to probably get some
fresh ones because i had to like dig
they were like buried in the bottom
drawer or something i didn't even know
where they were
i don't feel uh raw or ragged yeah i
haven't smoked in how long
many years five years no
four yeah it's been a long time it's
been several years yeah
so um let's see what i'm talking about
here
what are you talking about i remember
when tom would vape non-stop on the show
and jenny would jump on his ass for
being so loud
well and some people complained about
that too like never in the early days
well especially if you're just watching
if you were listening to like the audio
only version
yeah they were like i could see how yeah
like every now and then it's like [ __ ]
that guy why is he making so much
like [ __ ] vaping noise we don't want
to like listen to it that was back
before we were taking the show that
seriously
it kind of built up over time but then
you were putting all that down work into
the show
yeah with a lot more work in the show
back then just that we really didn't
expect to get anything out of it
it was just well i mean we as always we
just kind of started it
like for fun kind of yeah and
you know it's ironic because nowadays we
do a lot more shows during the week
but it's kind of it's a lot of work but
it's less work than it used to be
yeah she didn't get all the time
searching for photos because we only had
an audio we didn't have a video
component so i was like so the whole
time i was like
well i have to have a new photo like
every 10 seconds or whatever so people
don't get bored of looking that was kind
of the way
youtube was back then though it's true
yeah yes but we were
it wasn't the future of youtube it's
like the past of youtube
yeah um a lot of shows were like that
back then
but it's just so much easier just to do
it this way it's better for you guys to
actually see us
yeah i mean and even if we [ __ ] up or
like say stupid [ __ ] we shouldn't say
or can't remember some [ __ ] yeah i used
to worry about that a lot because i'd be
like oh man what if i like mess up or
what if i'm like um
and i can't remember something but now
i'm just like [ __ ] i don't care
i haven't vaped in a long time i got all
my vape stuff i just lost interest in it
don't didn't need it yeah and
yeah it's just more [ __ ] you have to
[ __ ] buy
to do well it's stuff you got to carry
with you and
you know and i just don't care anymore
too old to care
getting too old and too ugly to care
about that [ __ ]
he's too old to do it yeah too old too
ozzy
oh i was only pretty back in the day go
ahead and put that over there he was
only back in the day
well everybody can say that most people
were cuter back in the old days
i was telling you i was i showed sophie
this i was telling you about it that
this woman she was [ __ ]
overweight just [ __ ] up she's like 72
years old
she went to the gym she started taking
performance enhancing drugs she went
down to [ __ ] 125 pounds she looked
great for 72
and she did she spent her whole her
whole life out of shape
yeah she's got an instagram channel and
everything
yeah just oh you know what i mean it
doesn't matter you getting old
it doesn't matter not anymore it's not
like always like
kind of better yourself to a certain
degree you know what i mean
yeah but hey
i [ __ ] i [ __ ] had the pictures to
prove it i mean they got [ __ ]
you know genetics has a lot to do with
it if you were ugly
if you were ugly when you were young
come on
you're going to be ugly but everybody
can find somebody who who
you know everybody can find in a
significant other who is like them
you know you can't pick your parents
you know but you can't control that yeah
genetically some people
just they're just not gifted all right
but
certain people that [ __ ] look good
can remain good and remain
attractive into old age
and [ __ ] porn proved that they got
some they got some female porn stars
that are in their 70s
that are working it for [ __ ] 70.
[ __ ]
and they look like they they they play
the fetish [ __ ]
angle on their age and sure
what's her name old deangelo is her name
[ __ ] and she looks like
wicked witch of the west skinny big
boobs
white hair black stripes in it she knows
how to [ __ ] play the whole thing
and her whole [ __ ] business is the
older women fetish
okay see i feel like that's the
direction i need to go
i'm gonna i'm gonna be like an older one
yeah i'm gonna be like a scary
like witchy okay i'm gonna i'm gonna be
like a disney villain
yeah that's what she looks like i'm
gonna go disney villain that's what she
looks like she got some
that's a very attractive prospect yeah
right that's what she looks like
and well you might not have a choice at
70 or 80 that's probably how you go look
but that's okay though because it's like
a little too young to look like that now
yeah but i mean if i could go into like
a maleficent direction yeah
she went or like a [ __ ] or the witch
from snow white
version or new version on the show
[ __ ] weeks back i said you know
i know she looked crazy but it's they
got dudes that are [ __ ]
that's what i mean everybody there's a
niche for everybody
yeah i believe was it dida vantiste that
said you could be
what'd she say something like you could
be like [ __ ] work what you got no she
said something like
you could be like the best looking she
said something about peaches i do the
best looking peach in the room and
there's like
people that don't like peaches so she is
basically saying that
you could be the hottest chick ever and
there's always going to be some dudes
that aren't into you because
you're like not their type so don't
[ __ ] worry about it
there's always going to be like a
percentage of people that are going to
be into you whether that percentage is
large or small it doesn't really matter
but there's always going to be some so
just [ __ ] work it toward that
uh demographic i gotta thank t and
sabrina they're saying don't worry about
what you say jenny looking tom's still
good looking
see i never said you weren't okay he
said i was [ __ ] that was not the [ __ ]
i'm ugly no you said that
i didn't say that no look let me let let
me let me find [ __ ] what's her name
her name is sally deangelo i'm going to
show you
something oh i thought you're going to
try to blame such [ __ ] on me because you
said that
no i'm just i didn't let me let me tell
my story
i'm [ __ ] putting on the show that's a
show
people i'm gonna show you guys i thought
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show you uh
uh uh
um a um a g-rated
pitcher well yeah don't show up she's
like 70 shots there's a little porn on
here we're gonna
monetize like i don't care but don't get
demonetized
i mean you know we might get like that
but it'll be all right trying to find
one it's uh
look at him looking through like his
porn stash no i'm looking at google
what i'm just teasing you yeah he
doesn't know how to take a joke no well
you sound serious something
he doesn't understand my sense of humor
either you think that he would after ten
plus
years no this [ __ ] dries she still does
i saw that time you were living up in
the uk
he doesn't understand my dry ass she's
[ __ ] dry as [ __ ]
dry humor sometimes to an american just
means not funny
but it depends on the situation that's
only because you don't get it
yeah no no no i don't get it because a
lot of times i'll make a joke
which is obviously a joke and he'll try
to explain well no
actually blah blah i'm like dude i'm
joking i know yeah but it wasn't funny
so i didn't see this it was funny okay
might have been funny over in scotland
or whales
might have been funny to an intelligent
person oh something look at how she's
coming at me
hey you come at me one way i'm gonna
come out another way
not funny to dumb people
this [ __ ] man she's [ __ ] crazy oh
you're the only one that's allowed to be
a [ __ ]
we don't know we talked about that crazy
okay
tila says i don't want to see no old
porn lady tom
i'm looking right now i'm [ __ ]
getting lost in this [ __ ]
he's getting lost
[Laughter]
he's getting lost i'm trying to
entertain you [ __ ] man
i'm just trying to say what's possible
okay that's a decent picture
that i can show i thought you showed one
before but i can't
i can't remember what it looked like
though are you sure yeah i can't
it's not [ __ ] working for me what are
you doing grandpa are you like [ __ ]
the [ __ ] up
okay hey not bad for like 72.
she look good
well yeah you know yeah just saying this
anything's possible
she does look a little bit like a wicked
witch don't you but she
uh that's not a bad thing no it's not a
bad thing i guess
that you could chase like kids off your
lawn without you yeah
like i said i'm going full disney
villain to my old age yeah i'm just
warning you right now i'm going to go
like
maleficent on this [ __ ] how are you
doing on your drink you're all right
uh yeah i got like people are sending me
photos i got half of it left
oh okay [ __ ] he's going to show the
lady in the tub no they're shining
more
all right that's from the yearbook that
was from a play i did
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yes what are you
wearing fashion
underwear it says yeah remember that one
i don't know i've never seen that
picture before yeah
hold on what was that all about it was a
play
i know that dummy there's me [ __ ]
singing to steve and dear play that was
during joseph an amazing technicolor
dreamcoat
and he look at his face yeah he was
singing too it's like a duet
okay but it looks like he's going he's
going fast
that's because oh my god i was talking i
was playing the pharaoh man
and the pharaoh was also was the king
who means elvis and that's [ __ ]
singing this elvis song and i was
telling won't you tell me
you want you tell me some [ __ ] he's
going to tell me his [ __ ] prophecy
yeah that's granthar's the he got that
[ __ ] from the yearbook
oh he's sending me yearbook photos oh my
god
okay yeah we're seeing this that was
blurry [ __ ] grandpa
send that again that's just blurry i
can't say that
these are the pictures of the girls
that's grantha's in there actually
blurry bro how are you doing that was uh
one of those [ __ ] one of those
[ __ ] plays where that's uh
yeah those girls were cute man look how
big the hair the big hair
i remember that yeah i remember okay
he's trying to get he's trying to get me
and most of my friends had
still blurry bro had a [ __ ] bottle of
aussie
yeah hairspray in the locker yeah i had
a
hairspray it's just been smelling the
same since 90s
do i have aussie back here yeah you know
t
t white people have this [ __ ] called
aussie aaron hairspray
there you go that was our version of
jerry curl
that was jerry curl for white people it
had a [ __ ] special smell to it
it smelled good it smells i bring my
bags down every time i smell that [ __ ] i
was like
oh man i remember [ __ ] high school it
was just like it's like going back yeah
yeah i like it well it reminds me i had
this
friend and i hopefully okay it says it
reconnected
all right cool um is it going yeah it's
going
all right so i had a friend i think her
name was kathy but i can't remember
and she had um she had like normal like
blonde hair was long in the back but her
bangs
were like this they were like straight
up you know like
uh something uh there's something about
mary where she put the comm in her hair
and it was like the bankrupt like that
it looked like that
so it was like the 80s she had these
bangs like up here
so she always had like aussie like this
huge bottle of aussie like in her locker
and so i always associate the smell of
aussie
yeah with her yeah because she was she
was in my physics class she was in like
a couple other classes but it's like
it's funny because she was doing that
[ __ ] before there's something about mary
came out and then when i saw
that movie i was like oh my god it's her
from high school because her bangs
really straight up and that's what her
bags look like
oh my god [ __ ] high school team i'm
telling you man
if you ever get a chance if you don't
know what ozzie [ __ ] hairspray smells
like show that to her again
you don't know what that [ __ ] smells
like yeah i just ordered like i ordered
like
a three pack of these they're in the
other they're in the bathroom if you're
going through like
walgreens and you see that [ __ ] spray
some smell
you can go oh man that's what white
people smell like it's what white people
smell like
it did that's the way people use this
it's like i can't remember it's like
white people smell like two things ozzy
hairspray and bologna one of the two
i don't think there's any possible way i
could smell like blood
but okay because i haven't eaten bull
i haven't eaten bologna since i was like
12 years old
but what's in this though i don't know
it's kind of it's like a grapey kind of
smell
that smells good man he's going to spray
it like right in his face
i have three more of those it takes it
takes you back to another era yeah see
right
although the reason i buy it not just
for nostalgia because it smells good
but also because see instant freeze and
i'm like i don't want my bangs moving
yeah um the rest of my hair is fine i
can do whatever it wants to but i don't
like my
bangs flopping over into my face so i
just do my bangs over like that and i'm
like
it has a slight it's like a mixture of
[ __ ] if there's rape
there's nettles and [ __ ] in it it's like
a smell
the smell is a mixture of grape and
testers model
glue yeah it does kind of
smell like glue a little bit oh my god
that reminded me you got out of bed the
other day
yes saturday morning yeah she says you
smelling glue
yeah you made the whole bed smell like
yeah
model glue yeah you got out like to go
to the bathroom or something
and i was just kind of like yeah she
won't have sex i was [ __ ] fine
i was like you smell like glue like glue
i was like
you made the whole bed smell like glue
yeah i was like i have to wash the
sheets now
yeah that's those injections you and
your hormones yeah
injections oh my god i can't believe i
have to deal with this now and i'm like
almost 50 years old yeah
xanada says aussie smells good and
[ __ ] tea says uh
[ __ ] pantene dry shampoo is great oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i love dry shampoos because
honestly
i do not wash my hair every day because
you shouldn't
it's not good for your hair it dries it
out i wash my hair about every third day
um you know you get it wet you kind of
put water through it yeah i put water
through it i put conditioner in it you
she showers
you shower yeah you just don't wash the
hair no just get water through it yeah i
put water through it i put a little bit
of conditioner sometimes i put like some
of that oil like
i have enough hair to worry about it
well you don't
and honestly my hair every time i wash
my hair like you've complained about
this too every time i wash my hair
yeah big huge handfuls of it come out
yeah
and yet i don't my hair doesn't get
so you start talking about hair man we
lost seven people
like oh i could talk about watching man
[ __ ] that
yeah conspira normal hey good cause
we're gonna do their show next week okay
yeah yeah i think it's tuesday right
yeah tuesday tuesday it's 27 yeah what
are we talking we're gonna be what are
we gonna be talking about
because you gotta understand because
paranormal
they like me to [ __ ] run it on the
show and
in the [ __ ] season we just end up
talking about whatever the last couple
topics of the podcast were so we'll
probably talk about charles manson
right uh whatever the one before that
was
yeah which i don't even remember i've
been told i've been told
that some of some of tom's best content
is on paranormal is on [ __ ] um
conspiracy normal on their uh patreon
on their page well because we always do
extra [ __ ]
for the patreon show and then they just
let you run
rampant they ask me all kinds of good
questions that are crazy as [ __ ]
and he'll just go on and on and i'm over
here falling asleep yeah she'll fall
asleep but they want to hear
they want to [ __ ] hear because i
don't get a talk they know about a tom
rant
and i [ __ ] ran about all kinds of
stuff whatever it is they want to talk
about i enjoy it
i enjoy it because you know they said it
was a safe place for me to put them go
ahead and just cut loose
yeah which well you do that on here too
but like i said yeah i did too
quick let me get one but i'm also
another i'm also another person that
would like to talk sometimes
you know yeah but david asked me a
question
see these are good right i can order
more if you want they're good yeah order
some more i'm just afraid of being
addicted to them there's no nicotine
no they don't have any nicotine i don't
know what the [ __ ] in there but it's
not negative
they're hard to light
i noticed that's the problem like i said
they're not
um they're not ideal i prefer
actual cigarettes but um
they're good for just if you don't like
one up [ __ ]
yeah yeah he said uh adam says i'll send
you a list i love talking to tom about
brazil
yeah well yeah because he knows a lot
about brazil too because his
wife is from there yeah ex-wife ex-wife
is from there
so he lived down there for a while so
yeah you guys know all about brazil
i've never been there so i can't
contribute to the discussion
one of these days maybe
what take you down there i don't know
it's dangerous right now well that's
what i mean it's not my really top pick
if i'm going to spend money
it's like i don't that's not my top pick
of where i would want to go
brazil is very dangerous right now i'd
rather go to columbia than brazil
at least the war in colombia is over
we'll go up there and see our boy
amber yeah what's his name again i
forgot his name who jacob
jacob that's what i'm talking about yeah
jake yeah we could go yeah jacob's in
colombia
it's i don't know like i said you know
it's it's it's expensive to travel
there's a lot of it so it's not that bad
there's a lot of other places i'd rather
it's just
it's just the airline the air flight
it's about a thousand round trip per
person
or at least it was i gotta check it now
it probably maybe it's calm come down
well honestly
that's i used to pay let me get it and
get the cigarette
uh ashtray i used to pay 900 something
yeah to go to the uk yeah
round trip but that was non-stop
yeah you know what i mean i got friends
i grew up with in brazil though if we
went back to brazil i was sweet stay
with them
they're all doctors and lawyers now big
houses and [ __ ]
yeah okay yeah
i don't know i need to plan this [ __ ]
ahead of time i haven't had a vacation
in like more than 10 years
so i'm going to do a vacation i'm going
to [ __ ] do it right
yeah i'm going to do what i want to do
yeah time
t is saying that manson creepy
disappearances and the phoenix lights
were the last major talk
okay there you go so that's a good
that's a good uh okay so i can just read
back over those
notes and yeah we'll do that i still
would like to get more into the phoenix
lights
yeah that phoenix lights case was
[ __ ] very interesting
and that there was something there that
even ties into the whole crustal sphere
dude
yeah that is in part of the crustal
sphere and if [ __ ] crust
saw that [ __ ] then you know that [ __ ]
was real you could take that to the bank
he saw the lights he reported him he was
one of the first witnesses
so because what are those lights maybe
he didn't know what they
know what it was maybe called it in dom
the bomb says where would you like to go
jenny oh my god so many places
um honestly i would like to go
to italy i would like to go to greece
yeah i would like to go to japan
difference between all that well i know
that but i'm just i'm just blue sky in
here
yeah i'd love to go to japan man there's
a lot of place in the us i'd like to go
i'd love to go to [ __ ]
alaska i want to see all the [ __ ]
ice sheets i want to see all that kind
of [ __ ] i could i feel right at home in
korea
i haven't lived there japan would just
has a better nightlife they don't look
at you like you're from another planet
they would look at me and you dressed up
for the nighttime like we were from
another [ __ ] planet in korea
they would they don't treat you too well
especially if you have tattoos
japan is a little more tolerant of
foreign ways
you know what i mean they have golf
clubs there well yeah
i mean japanese people do well in japan
korea didn't have golf clubs
you'd be we'd end up on hooker hill
yeah that's their version of the [ __ ]
well like i said i've always kind of
want to go to japan it's something
you know what i mean it's like price
differences there's a lot of places i
want to go in europe still
um but i would like to go to japan
before i die
the problem with japan is that most
people would want to go to [ __ ] would
would want to go to tokyo and tokyo is
amazingly expensive and a lot of people
have said that
other cities outside of tokyo are better
well i mean tokyo is very touristy it's
very
yeah it's touristy and it's overcrowded
yeah which you know
overpriced i get that
then it says norway the fatherland well
i would actually like to go to
scandinavia
uh you know not much of a party life
well just to see it you know
cold and dark i like that though
i like cold and dark okay i'm not into
this like
sunny [ __ ] i don't i don't like this
yeah because you were born here
i grew up here it's i'm over it yeah you
know what i mean it's like you don't get
that
i'm over it it's it's not
seriously i get up here and it's raining
hockey motherland
i get up here and it's raining that
makes me super happy okay
i'm like hooray the sun's not out today
yeah
i don't like it i'm not i'm not into it
south africa is breathtakingly beautiful
violent as hell though
yeah i don't think south africa white
people run from south africa i know a
lot of them they're just like oh no
sorry
not a good place to go tila says i
should go to alaska
bend a juno page and yeah okay
yeah i've always wanted to do like i
don't i'm not a cruise person
but i've always wanted to go to alaska
that seems like like my vibe
i like mountains i like snow i gotta
tell you jenny hi on my list right now
would be mexico
i would love to go to mexico after some
of the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
um these [ __ ] mexican guys that are
in here
looking you know to some of the
photographs that they showed me
fantastic i would
gain 50 pounds if we went to mexico what
we could get in mexico for the dollar
[ __ ] the money that we have now
amazing
have a good time the problem is is like
you said it's hot and sunny it's
kind of like it's not as bad as florida
the humidity is a lot
but it's not different enough that it
would i mean one of the best times that
i had
i always have a good time going on
vacation to somewhere that's not like
here
so i always have a good time i always
have a good time in new york city i
always had a good time
i went out to colorado and i went up in
the mountains because my sister used to
live there
and i went up in the mountains and it
was like snow and it was like and i had
the [ __ ] it was so awesome
because it was different i mean i had a
really good time out there
starbucks it's easter island nah man
i like giant heads
[Laughter]
chile would be better than easter island
i wouldn't i wouldn't he's making a joke
you get that yeah i know that
yeah i [ __ ] went to santiago when i
was in
santiago for like two weeks i [ __ ]
loved it chile was great
beautiful i was it was a teenager at the
time i gotta tell you man
just saying see i would be into if we
went to
central south america i want to see all
that old like aztec and olmec [ __ ] man
i want to go see the [ __ ] temples
yeah i'm going to go out in the jungle
and see that i want to see that [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean yeah it's out
there i like that [ __ ] peru had a lot of
it peru
yeah yeah i like that [ __ ] i'm in all
he's not because
he makes fun of me because he thinks i'm
like already farting and [ __ ] but i like
all that
i like that old like archaeological [ __ ]
man
yeah see that [ __ ] it's touristy now
though
yeah there aren't as many too they're
probably
probably it's not that crowded most of
the time you can find out
when the slow season is again go that's
probably the best way to do it well
obviously
yeah and don't go anywhere that's like
not sanctioned because i read the ruins
i know you go to some [ __ ] place and
they like [ __ ] the vines eating yeah
santa says tom my uncle vacations in
chile multiple times yeah chile was
[ __ ] awesome
it was still during the rain pinochet i
believe was still in charge at that time
and it was just a quiet peaceful place
it was kind of had of a weird
kind of had a weird germanic feel to it
a lot of irish immigration there um
people think of south america you know
they're thinking
of like a place like mexico no not more
like europe
that's what it's like you did have
indigenous people there but they're all
just kind of [ __ ] bred into the
people mostly you know it's not
and it was uh chile was i liked chelated
great
and i'm and i was going to say this out
of all of south america
chileans were handsome handsome people
just very handsome
they just looked good real good just
something about
their breeding i don't know they're just
looking real good looking people
um i would i kind of put them at the
in terms of just the aesthetic
pretty damn good looking
they're just good-looking people i can
show you pictures
just the way they look i don't know why
i don't know either
just the way they look granthar says
thailand was tripped never seen anything
like the ping pong shows and the strip
clubs they shouldn't like ping pong
balls out there
cooches what have the ping pong probably
worked yeah
well that's a pretty common thing
thailand is known for that kind of [ __ ]
and um if you're into the [ __ ] muscle
steroid [ __ ] scene
thailand's huge for that a lot of your a
lot of your [ __ ]
um uh uh bodybuilders go there to
[ __ ] do
cycles of [ __ ] steroids and [ __ ]
hang out with uh hang out with thai
girls
or thai lady boys that's another one
they like thai ladyboys
they can there's a famous [ __ ]
bodybuilder what's his name [ __ ]
i'm trying to remember his name uh
he's just this big funny looking
[ __ ] who's just ridiculous as
[ __ ]
and he ended up becoming not really a
laughingstock but just
kind of like uh in the
in in the [ __ ] bodybuilding scene he
just became a trip because he was making
[ __ ] porn
and he's goofy the dude is just goofy as
[ __ ] he's an old guy in his 50s
uh trying to remember what his name was
though when you see him he's just
[ __ ] a trip
you know big pot billy muscle muscle
dude
yeah thailand is trip but amazing food
my co-worker was thai i wouldn't mind it
going there actually
i mean i know that it has kind of like a
bad reputation it's like oh that's where
all the
dudes go to like bang underage yeah
you know it's obviously and uh that's
that's not the whole
i think a lot of thai food was [ __ ]
bugs they eat a lot of bugs
yeah but that's not all they [ __ ] no
but it was when i was when i was younger
that's just like saying oh all the
scotsy just haggis yeah that's not
the case it's so everybody's known by
like their grossest thing
bugs eating bugs was not the normal
thing that thailanders ate though they
i feel like that there's some kind of
[ __ ] where it's like hey let's give this
to the foreigners to gross them out no
go away and leave us alone that's not
what happened according to
according to a chef that i that i was
listening to
thailand got [ __ ] kind of infected
with communism for a while and during
that time a famine got hit and they all
started eating bugs
and [ __ ] they were just finding and that
that was not their original
cuisine uh their original cuisine was
you know
fish and chicken and the same kind of
[ __ ] other people
eat but during the time during times of
communism they eat bugs
and famine and so and that got kind of
blended in i guess
i guess it's kind of like their version
of crawdads and crawfish but
still i'm just not eating any goddamn
roaches i'm just not eating them but
like i said you can understand where
that came from and like i said
after a time i feel like people's
uh cuisine gets identified by like their
grossest thing
or like what other people in other
countries think is their grossest thing
you know what i mean so it's like people
talk about scandinavia and they're like
oh my god you get that rotten fish
that's like been buried in the earth or
whatever it's like they're not eating
that every day most of the time people
eat normal [ __ ]
it's just that you know or the same [ __ ]
that everybody else eats
but it's just you get you know kind of
type cast into this one sort of thing
and it's like nobody's eating that every
day
you know what i'm saying unless you have
to china eats a lot of bugs
they eat a lot of bugs that's normal for
them though i saw a chinese dude pick up
a damn live living frog and bite the
head off of it and halfway through the
head of the damn frog and eat it
and uh and it was it wasn't food it had
something to do with some kind of a
chinese
medicine that dude well yeah that's a
different thing
and i was just like nah but they were
serving it in a restaurant
and i was like nah nah i mean um
if you want to know about what's going
on in china you go on a channel
um [ __ ] what's his name
[ __ ] i'm too drunk to remember people's
names now
and um anyway
he lived there for nearly i think more
than a decade he was a south african guy
married a chinese woman and everything
they left there from now
they left there now but he'll tell you
everything about all the food and why
they were eating it and
how much it cost and food quality and
what's
what's a ripoff and what is in a ripoff
uh his name is serp
the channel is called serpent za
that it's a really really good channel
and he used to stream from there live
but not anymore
but i learned a lot about shenzhen i
think it's where he lived in china
and just how they do things not as
exciting as i thought it would be
um nothing ever is yeah you'd get bored
with it quick
uh you you stay in some tourist area
well living somewhere
is different than visiting somewhere
what ended up happening with china if
you went to visit china
you'd stay in a tourist area because
there really wouldn't be much for you to
do outside of there that you would like
and then in that tourist area you'd be
get bored quick
because it's very watered down
very westernized so it's not the real
china
and a couple people made the point too
that it's like there's a lot of [ __ ] to
see in the u.s which
actually i would really like
one day before i die i would really like
to do like a train journey across the
whole us
or do uh route 66 or do any of that kind
of [ __ ]
we watched like a documentary on youtube
like a dude and his dad had driven route
66 and they stopped everywhere along the
way
and it's like i was kind of like man i
kind of feel like i'm gonna do that like
i either want to do a road trip or i
want to do like a train trip across u.s
if you're flying across it's not the
same you don't get to see [ __ ]
i want to like stop at all the like
cheesy roadside attractions i want to do
all that kind of [ __ ] i want to see all
the [ __ ]
mountains and the canyons and all that
kind of [ __ ] i want to do that
one of these days yeah i don't know
we'll see not me thank you
i'll do it i'm going to go long too long
no it'll be fun
it'd be fun about it what is that of two
weeks well i don't know yeah
and it'll train all that time yeah and
it it ended up being for us it would be
kind of like the same wherever you went
not really yeah like i said i went to
colorado and that was like really not
like here and i went to new mexico and
it was really not like here
i've been to most of these states i
think so well
you can just you can just sit in the
bedroom and watch youtube
and all go have some fun
the united states has become kind of
homogenized in a certain way
recently you know but well yeah whatever
don't be a bummer tonight not being a
bomber yeah you are just saying for the
money i'd rather go to another country
well yeah so would i but i'm just saying
there's a lot of cool [ __ ] that i
haven't seen in the u.s
also and i'm just saying that a few
years ago
i went to colorado to see my sister
yeah and it was amazing the mountains
were amazing
because i'm from florida we don't have
mountains um
you know we don't have mountains that
had still had snow on them in [ __ ]
may or june or whatever it was
and it was like cool i'd never been on a
mountain and there were clouds like
below you that blew my [ __ ] mind
yeah you know what i mean i've never
seen that
so you know i thought that was really
cool it was it was just kind of like the
first time i went to the uk
i went to wales and it snowed
and i had never seen snow in my entire
life well i'd seen snow but like just
little flakes of it i never seen snow
like
snow on the ground where you could build
a snowman i've never seen that ever
yes because i grew up in florida yeah
it's kind of ridiculous
it doesn't snow here yeah well it snowed
that one time still back in 2008
yeah but that's not snow snow it's like
snow is like little flakes are falling
out of the sky
it did though but it doesn't build up on
the ground to a point where you could
build it up it did out and used this and
i was living in houston
it snowed it stayed on the ground
i guess it just didn't hear that was
2008. well i live it only happens like
once
i grow up i grew up on the coast okay it
would snow
every now and then um you would get it
it would snow
sometimes you get little uh flakes
everyone to freak out
because it never happened but it
wouldn't really stay on the ground
if it did it wouldn't really stay for
more than like an hour or two
i never had like this much snow like i
was in the first time i was in
wales i think it was january it was a
january and it was like 2002
2001 2002 something like that and it
like it was a bad snowstorm it was like
worse than they usually had
and there was like several feet of snow
like so much that people couldn't drive
and [ __ ] yeah
and i went in the backyard my
ex-husband's parents house
i was like i'm gonna build a [ __ ]
snowman because i've never done that in
my entire life
so i went up and i built a [ __ ]
snowman just so i could say that i had
done that because it was like
it was blowing my mind i just i had
never seen that and it's really weird to
me because
you know for people most you know most
people in the united states
you know it snows in the winter time
florida it doesn't
so i had never seen that before yeah
i've seen it movies and [ __ ] but i never
experienced it me and granters are just
like going what is she talking about
because
i've been missing that [ __ ] no that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
so people don't understand like
it's it's almost kind of like you know
you know people that um grew up in
australia
where you know in the southern
hemisphere and
you know christmas happens in the
summertime so all their christmas like
oh
santa's surfing and all that other kind
of [ __ ] that's kind of like what florida
is like
um it's like it gets kind of cold here
sometimes
but it doesn't snow
it's not like even a lot of times at
christmas time it's still like warm
yeah i never saw i saw
snow in the sense that oh there's like
little
flakes falling and every now and then
sometimes it would get cold enough and
we would
uh convince my parents or my grandma or
whoever
to turn the sprinklers on so the grass
would freeze so we could pretend like it
was snow
you know what i mean so we got all the
grass well yeah but well that's why she
didn't want to do it
and she was like i'll kill all the grass
we're like we don't care we just want to
pretend it's like winter time
so well because we saw in the movies and
we wanted to be winter time
so we were just like just freeze your
whole yard please we were kids
t said you'd love this uh sequoia and
sequoia national forest that's true yeah
redwood forest
yeah we go there as a kid all the time
when i lived in california
yeah one of the best places about hook
in yosemite is the way yosemite smells
it smells like redwood the whole [ __ ]
place
and that there's it's just real it's got
cool
crisp air and you smell that redwood
smell
mixed with campfires the smell of
campfire is burning see i love that
smell
yeah it's pretty nice i mean i haven't
been there in a long long time it was
just something
you know as a kid that i experienced
it's pretty out there
real pretty and i don't know if
when we went me and my aunt lois and
like some of my aunts
it was never crowded really it might be
now i don't know the population has
expanded a lot since that time
and the forest rangers were cool they
would sell you weed
they would just give you weed if your
ants were cute
and young like they were back in the day
that i would go there they just come up
with [ __ ]
guitars and farts start around the
campfire and start [ __ ]
sticking right there yes
you said fart instead of starting not to
say anything about
foreign
okay and um start um
[ __ ] playing guitar and [ __ ]
handing out [ __ ] joints
and try to they try to [ __ ] your ants
that's what i try to do yeah
that's why they were given the free
wheat yeah that's what it was
that's that's 70s though
70s and early 80s i don't know if tila
had the
had the experience of the forest rangers
trying to [ __ ] your ass
but that's just the way it works
with weed yeah they're trying to flying
them with weeds they're singing they're
[ __ ] playing guitar and singing
singing rocky mountain high colorado
you know like i said [ __ ] singing
john denver [ __ ] songs
pope songs yeah yeah and they have like
one token female
uh um so they didn't seem predatory
no they have one token female [ __ ] uh
ranger with them at all times yeah like
i said so they didn't i remember that i
remember
she was cute her name was zoe zoe and
she was but not
zoey zelly it might have been zoey but i
remember i thought she said so
okay remember well some people like it
and
the the uh the the main forest ranger
[ __ ] park ranger thing the barracks
are right there
and uh we actually went into her [ __ ]
apartment
and she had all these because she was
selling artwork okay
and she would um she had these
hand-drawn inks
of [ __ ] things like owls and all
these forestry they were [ __ ]
gorgeous it was like profession she was
like a professional artist
and a and a forest ranger because my
aunts were friends with her
yeah i remember that you're just gonna
come back
yeah and then that's that's how it was
kind of like a hippie days
they're all old people now if not dead
well what i remember from florida which
like i said never snows here we don't
have winter
yeah um so we would go camping at
springs in central florida
and you would uh try to avoid getting
eaten by alligators
and you would try to avoid getting
encephalitis from mosquitoes
and try to avoid getting heat stroke
but it was fun other than that yeah but
it was super hot although i do remember
one time we went camping
i think it was it might have been in
alexander springs which is in
central florida like it's near ocala and
we went camping there
and it was in march and i remember that
it was unseasonably
cold the night that we camped for some
reason just like out of the blue
and it went down into the [ __ ] 30s in
march
yeah which is crazy um
so my mom and my brother were in the
tent
and me and my sister were like [ __ ] this
we're gonna go sleep in the station
wagon which is my mom's station wagon
so we go to sleep in the state because
we thought it would be warmer it wasn't
yeah spoiler alert so we go sleep in the
station wagon
and in the station wagon um
we had a cockroach who had decided
that the station wagon was warmer than
the outside so he was gonna live
in the station wagon and was also trying
to get
into our sleeping bags all night so we
did not
sleep that entire night of that [ __ ]
trip
as soon as the sun came up we were like
just running just get this [ __ ] bug
out of this [ __ ] car because yeah
he was very persistent i mean i get it
he was cold we were cold
but i'm like get the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
yeah uh
xander mentioned he's at lake tahoe he
santa sent me some videos
today him driving through the mountains
and shooting some video down on [ __ ]
lake tahoe he's down there right now
look
look gorgeous look good how long has the
uh
show been going on jenny is it time for
us to go ahead and check off
uh three hours and four days it might be
around time it looks like this
looks like everybody's kind of slowing
down
super chat's drying up it might be time
to shut it down
you gonna make some food or some [ __ ]
yeah we'll get something to eat i'm
getting
i'm getting hungry you getting hungry
what do you want kinda want some
hamburgers you want uh
what you got well i don't know we hadn't
like tacos or burritos
that was a long long time ago i don't
have any i don't have a whole lot of
things
thought so okay hamburger probably way
to go
all right we could have a hamburger
that's fine but yeah so
hopefully you guys had a good time
tonight i know we need to talk about
death brief that much but
i guess we'll talk about it sunday we've
got to review it i didn't realize that
that was what you were doing that's the
idea that's why we watched it
oh okay yeah i didn't realize so i guess
we'll have to do it
all right fair enough yep so i'll change
the title on this okay
it doesn't really matter because i just
change title all right so
we will see you guys when okay so it's
wednesday okay so we'll see you guys
friday evening yeah we are doing a show
about
cruise ship crimes that was what won in
the thing so i found like a whole bunch
of crazy
murders and disappearances and [ __ ] that
happened on cruise ships he says hit the
like button people
yeah everybody needs to hit the like
button that's right that's how the
algorithm works
everybody's saying good night good night
everybody good night tammy yeah you guys
have a good rest of your night and we
will see you guys
on friday night yep thank you very much
for dropping by
yep we'll see you guys later see you
dave
bye